It's so loud!
Welcome to Spooky's Chopska Mansion!
Welcome.
Ah, ghost!
I think I will be the spookiest thing here.
I think.
Why am I so small?
Oh, um...
Is that better?
I hope you guys enjoy the game!
With my face covering the whole thing!
Much better.
Bigger!
I am the game.
I think it's as big as I can get.
Uh...
Anyway.
Meow.
Oh.
Anyway.
Welcome.
Um, I've never played this game before.
I'm ready to get jumped out of my pantaloons.
I'm ready.
Stop staring at me with them big ol'
Smaller.
Once you go big, there ain't going back.
Go big or go home, baby.
Played the original before.
I never played the original.
I never played the new one.
I've seen sometimes people playing this game, so I truly
know like nothing about it.
Actually, truly, truly nothing.
Headphone users turn the volume down.
Oh, actually thank you for reminding me because I do want to
turn my volume down.
I turned it down a little bit before.
Oh.
This is nice.
I love how you can turn the jump scares off.
Isn't this a jump scare mansion?
Wait, this is kind of nice.
This is chill.
I like that you can turn off the headbob.
Oh, yeah, let's turn that off.
What, should I keep motion blur on or off?
I can't remember what people like more.
Calm before the scare.
Off?
Okay.
That should be good then.
The hell is in the bottom right corner?
What are you...
Um, the scariest thing you'll see all day.
Um...
Your nightmare?
Your... your parasocial demon?
Wait, uh, wait, what's it called?
Um...
No, wait, what's that word?
The night demon that... The ones that make you not able to
move.
Um...
What is that called?
What is that?
The parallel...
Allalysis demon!
Sleeper house.
Oh my god.
Good morning, Minto.
It's my birthday today.
I'm gonna get a spoopy, happy bub song.
Of course.
Wait, how do I say your name?
Ganymede.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Ganymede.
I hope I said your name right.
If I didn't, I'm so sorry.
but it's your birthday so it doesn't matter!
Happy birthday to you!
Parallelogram demon.
But yeah, I'm not scared at all.
Oh, I missed the old music.
This one makes me want to act up a little bit.
What if this was my house, you know?
Parasocial demon.
She's got such a way with words.
You mean you aren't already?
I'm not even at half my power.
I got something in my eye.
Hold on.
Spooky parenthesis demon.
Are we ready to start the game?
Are you guys ready to get your socks knocked?
You guys are gonna scream so much!
Oh wait, which one do I do?
Karamari Hospital?
Wait, should I just do the regular one?
Renovated version of the original jump scare mansion?
Not my socks.
Last thing you see before the end is mint, broomie rock.
And check out Six with a toady!
Can you hold my hand?
Okay.
The mansion?
Mansion?
Okay!
Renovated version of the original jump scare mansion.
Oh.
Wow!
This...
This mansion's not big enough for the two of us.
A thousand.
Oh.
Is that...
Anyway, just go.
Oh.
There she goes.
I can do that too.
Watch, watch, watch, watch.
I can do this.
Um.
Oh, it pauses me.
Never mind.
Um.
So a thousand rooms, eh?
Okay.
Can you do it?
I could if I wanted to, but I don't feel like it right now.
All right, left or right, everybody.
Is that Marcelline's sister?
My parasocial demon ghost me.
Stop!
Left, okay.
That was a test for you guys.
Did you guys jump at my scream?
Left or right?
Well, we went left last time.
Okay.
I think I have a stamina.
Maybe.
Wow.
So lovely.
Room 5, we're already killing it with time.
Oh, I think the...
Okay, I do have stamina.
Okay, that's good to know.
Oh, what's here?
We can take a little break.
Or...
I call the bunk bed...
Oh, there's something over here, too.
I am afraid of no toast.
I don't think I can interact with these.
I have a bunk bed IRL.
What?
What was that?
Hmm.
Wow, the atmosphere is lovely here.
I'm gonna go to this room.
I call top bunk.
Too late, slow poke.
I've already called every bunk in the bed.
Wait, why am I doing that?
These Minecraft looking beds.
Minecraft looking air beds.
Nice.
Wow, this place is huge!
Um, gochijin-sama!
Actually, you know what?
I'm kind of glad I'm not a maid for this place.
I would have to clean every single area here!
Can you imagine...
What was that?
Can you imagine?
I would be scrubbing every single little stone!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
No, PNG bones!
The skinny legend died here!
No!
Rip, rip skinny legend.
So far, this has been a breeze.
Spooky, scary skeletons, and shivers up your spot.
Oh my god, there's more!
Yeah, I could use his bones to cause the fire.
Strike a fire, I mean.
We're not causing a fire.
Hmm.
The stamina goes down real fast.
Oh.
What interesting decor.
Oh, there's more bones.
It's a mirror.
I'm looking mighty fine today.
Little wispy, you know.
Oh.
More bones.
What's that sound?
Is it you?
I think I'm gonna keep going.
Ah!
What's that?
Why does it sound so rumbly?
Look at that head.
So cute.
Why is it...
Oh.
Reed.
At first this place seemed cute.
I've been here for a few days now.
I feel quite parched.
I'm getting this feeling like I'm being watched or
something.
This is not romantic at all!
What's that sound?
Wait, didn't I come from here?
Did I go the wrong way?
No, room 23.
So there's notes, okay.
Good to know.
Wait, the more I go...
Okay, that sound is disappearing.
Is something...
Is something chasing me?
not so romantic uh oh it's loud again uh oh there's no notes
is it the paintings
oh wait I was gonna say the guy in the picture is gone let's
go to the right tummy um what are you talking about i ate uh
i'm not gonna go towards the sound i'm gonna go in here oh
locked just kidding i have to go towards this out png bones
are lost cookie clicker save i'll be honest oh there's a
note i know something oh i know something is following me
but i feel like i'm prancing through the same rooms over and
over that's what i just said hopefully leaving doses
breadcrumbs will prove i'm making progress and reaching some
destination i just hope i don't run out of ink i am
dreadfully thirsty he's gonna start using his blood
wait he's just like me i said that same thing i said i think
i'm going through this did i go through this room before my
mom already going crazy
get used to that we're already through room 34.
What does that sound?
I've learned that blood for the blood god.
Ah!
It's from Warhammer.
Ink.
Not quite quenching my thirst.
Taste is terrible.
Stains are terrible.
I don't think drinking it was a very romance.
Why is everything about the romance?
Is this supposed to be like a honeymoon suite or...
Am I supposed to be...
Am I...
Are they chasing me here because I booked the room by
myself?
I'm supposed to be with someone lovely or...
This area looks familiar too.
Oh, we can go in!
Oh.
Maybe I should run.
Adventurous romance.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Don't lock me out!
Oh.
We saw this one before.
And this one before.
Oh.
That's a little spooky.
I don't really like that one.
What was that noise?
Nice to see you.
Still there.
Learn how to sprint.
I know!
Wait, is this different from sprinting?
Is running different?
I found something today to satisfy my unromantic thirst.
I awoke today from a brief faint and found before me a
bottle of red wine.
I'm not sure what brand or year, for there is no label.
All I gather is that it tastes strongly metallic.
Metallic.
Oh, buddy, I don't think that was wine.
I think you just got a good case of iron.
As long as he thinks it's wine, it's fine, right?
But also, wouldn't it, like, taste so horribly?
Okay, we're almost to 50.
Can I go in these now?
Oh!
I had a saying!
Oh, you can do it.
We can help.
Papa Jones.
That's different from the Papa I know.
Where's my lovely romantic evening?
Down?
Uh-oh.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What is happening?
Go-shujin-sama!
The whole room is an elevator, yeah.
Oh, no!
She's going down, down, and she's rolling around.
I don't think that was wine.
I told you, bro.
I warned you about the wine, bro.
This looks familiar.
familiar to this room.
It keeps happening.
Oh!
You are here.
The rooms are spinning and moving.
Oh!
I'm getting my cardio in.
Didn't expect a little guy like that, though.
Oh!
I'm gonna avoid that.
Spouting, splashing, Innerds ingest invoking.
Nailing never stops the choking.
Oh.
Oh god.
Wait.
Oh no no no no no no no no no no
no.
Oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no.
I don't even touch it though.
This is messed up.
Oh god.
I picked the wrong room.
Why am I so slow in the beginning?
No no no no.
Oh god.
They're still coming.
I picked the wrong room.
Don't look back, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to die here.
Don't come at me.
This way.
Don't be locked.
They don't stop coming and they don't stop...
I have a question.
Is this all randomly generated or is there like kind of a...
A pumpkin!
Is there kind of a rhyme or reason?
Am I good now?
Yes.
Do what?
Are they still coming?
Maybe not.
It's random.
Sort of random, but not really.
So many bones.
It's a roguelike.
Oh, that's so fun.
No notes, though.
Every X level is a certain theme for us.
Okay.
Very cool.
Nothing here.
Can you fight?
I don't think so.
Oh, this is fun.
Let's go this way.
Lala, this is actually kind of romantic.
I don't know what he's talking about.
I feel.
I needed a fun stream today.
Good morning, Binto.
Good morning.
He's still in the same spot.
Oh, we have a new guy.
Look at him.
Boink.
Let's keep going.
Are they still locked?
Fancy.
Toy horse or banana?
It looked like a banana like he was eating, but it big old
banana to me.
Yeah, I think this is actually quite romantic.
Nothing else I would want.
Oh, shoot.
No, please.
No, no.
No!
I changed my mind!
This isn't romantic at all!
No!
Oh my god.
What is this?
Oh, I didn't go the wrong way.
This isn't romantic!
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Please tell me no.
Oh, I didn't go the wrong way.
I want the wrong way!
I want the right way!
Please.
Let me through.
Really?
Leave me alone!
Why are you guys so obsessed with me?
Ah!
Oh my god, these goo piles, I swear.
Run, run, run, run.
That one looked like me.
Um, I will take my royalties now.
Oh my god.
Legally distinct Minto.
Oh, Nicholas Cage!
Better ingredients, better pizza.
Oh, pasta.
Sorry.
I think my cat sees a bird.
Her tail's going a little bit.
little crazy.
Better ingredients, better pasta.
That's the power of the Home Depot.
They're in your head.
They truly...
I just said it instinctually.
Keep a little pep on your step.
Oh, this place is cute.
I have always found the Windows 95 3D maze screensaver
romantic.
Yes!
You derail MVP.
I can't believe I did that in first I can't believe I
figured out I or rather I went the right ways and I didn't
even know it first best worst way to spend my birthday what
no fake smiley what do you mean the best worst way
hmm what do you mean happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear
smiley happy birthday to you happy birthday oh good let's go
I feel like I could be a little jump scare in this baby corn
thanks for the 10 gifted oh what's this say I don't know how
much longer I could go on I haven't seen any of my previous
notes so that means either I'm getting somewhere or someone
is taking them What kind of monster will we approach?
Will we?
Oh.
Will we, um, see this time.
I feel like I'm an Indiana Jones!
I like this.
Oh, what's that?
What's wrong?
What's happening?
But there's a note here.
There's, that was such a surprise.
surprise that there will be another entry, another actual
entry.
One I could admire.
Then as suddenly as I came, it left, and now you disband.
Your influence and inspiration will never leave me.
What is it?
Oh, okay.
Well, I actually can't go through any of these.
Maybe.
Ah!
Oh.
Is it gone?
Uh.
No!
Oh.
Uh.
Huh?
No!
Why am I MPT?
Um...
No!
Do I go back?
No?
Huh?
Where do you know?
Open door?
Oh!
Okay, okay.
There's puzzles like...
There's puzzles in this game.
Interesting.
Oh, shoot.
Can I fall off?
You know what?
Maybe I shouldn't try.
But why would they give me the option to fall off if I
couldn't fall, you know?
The mint never falls off.
I don't think I can.
No, I don't think I can.
That's good to know then.
This one's really long.
Oh, they even have paintings down here.
This one is really romantic with the with the sexy cages the
mood lighting oh and the the goop the most romantic of it
all probably let's go straight
more goop this is where my My lovely slime girlfriend lives.
You know?
Oh, he's still chilling there.
He's like in the same spot.
How does the goop taste?
Probably like a line.
What is that?
How?
Anyway.
Oh!
First up, oh, Mary finally.
Third is Bram.
And he is stoked to be here.
Mrs. Spook!
Everyone's been waiting for Mito!
Feel like Gupu'd love Gwyneth Paltrow.
Who's that?
What's this one?
All of the Spooks!
Spooky car!
Oh, it's out of order.
Um, which one do you guys want to play?
No?
To the games?
Oh.
I'm already playing.
Meow.
No one's gonna slow me down, baby.
There's no jump scares in this game, are there?
Wow!
Dorifto!
Why are the cars not on the road?
Why are the cars...
Oh gosh, I feel like I'm gonna play...
You know that commercial of the car?
And then... Oh, I just killed a person, I think.
Oh!
I just...
Sorry.
Um...
Oh, I have to kill them!
Oh!
Oh, oops.
I thought I was just driving.
Oh, I took out a tree!
Vehicular Man Slider!
Oh, yeah!
Wait, oh, they're still spinning.
Four!
Five!
There they go.
Hey, you're not allowed to be here.
There we go!
Oh, we'll come back to him, I think.
Oh my gosh, I gotta kill them all first.
Yeah!
But you know that commercial of the car, like, driving, and
then it has the pop-up zombie, and it, like, got everybody
as a kid.
Oh, I hit that tree before once.
Hey, where'd all these cars come from?
Yeah!
The ancient jump scare.
I know, uh...
That's what I feel like it's gonna happen here.
Wait, this is only stage one.
I wasted so much time thinking that I was just supposed to
drive around.
Oh, here's a guy.
Oh, I wasn't looking at the road!
I took out two trees!
Where's the rest of the cars?
Hello?
Yeah, deforestation, everybody.
Oh, there's a guy.
Two guys.
You killed them all.
No, there's three left!
This is so fun.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, one guy, one guy, one guy.
Get one guide, get one guide, get one guide, get one guide.
Get one guide, get one guide, get one guide.
Is that what she says?
Is there a special for taking out the trees too?
No really, where is he?
I'll take out the trees while I'm waiting.
Get the one guy.
I'm looking for him!
He's a trickster!
Where is he?
Imagine if you miss.
That would be so... Oh!
Yay!
Oh, how do I get out?
There we go.
That was good fun.
Wait, I kind of want to play all of them now.
Oh my god!
I'm...
Oh my god.
This is...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, okay, I do have to press.
Oh, ow.
What's the point of this one?
Oh.
Kind of a bot, though.
I should just have my auto...
Oh my god, the flashing is kind of killing me, though.
Oh my god, why is it flashing so much?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, it's flashing a lot.
Oh, I don't like this one, though.
This one flashes too much.
Who am I?
Am I spooky?
What am I...
Am I collecting these?
What am I doing?
I'm not even eating them.
Nothing's happening.
Oh, there he is!
He's eating them!
Ah!
Spooky Inception.
Metagamer.
I don't know.
Introducing some ghosts.
First up is Minta!
Like an inverse Pac-Man.
Yeah, I...
Oh, whoops, my bad.
There we go.
Yeah, I was spooky.
That was a fun little break.
Back into the spooky mansion.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
SCP?
Whoa.
What?
What the hell is this?
Wow!
Oh my god!
Raptor head!
Meatman.
Well, babe.
Uh-oh.
That's not good.
I think this means something bad.
What's here?
Subject 5 is growing more and more restless.
I told Spook we need more funds for sedatives.
But she just laughed and flew into the ceiling.
Without more chemicals to keep these things docile.
I'm not sure how much longer we can keep them here safely.
generic lab assistant.
I got the key card.
Where does that take me, though?
Uh-oh.
Something's really loud.
It sounds like something's right behind this door.
What is that?
Uh-oh.
He's gonna come out of the ceiling.
I believe subject five is loose!
The glass around its container is shattered, and I can
faintly hear clicking coming from the ceiling.
I don't know what will happen now.
If it is out and alive, then it is probably my last resort.
The clicking is getting louder now.
Oh no, generic loud.
Oh shoot.
How did I live?
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
Oh my god.
It's not...
Oh, I kind of hear the click.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh god.
Oh god, he's gonna kill me.
Oh, God, he's gonna kill me real.
Oh, God.
I'm trying to run.
I'm trying to sprint.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
This is messed up.
Get out of my eyes.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
He's gonna come out from the ceiling.
Oh, yep.
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna run to the end.
Yep.
Ah!
Ice cream!
We all scream!
Four!
Oh, shoot.
I wasn't gaming.
I should have...
I should have known.
Is it the same layout as before?
If it is.
Yes, it is!
Hallelujah!
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I think I'm safer now.
The music stopped.
Eric, thanks for the ice cream.
I want some cookies and cream right now.
Oh, my health regenerated even.
How kind.
Me?
Free ice cream!
Oh, you're the brains behind this ice cream.
Operation A.
Hmm.
Very cool.
Which way did I come from?
135.
Oh.
Green.
Goop room.
Subject 5 is probably the main specimen that scares me way
more than the goop.
Is there some...
Wait, should I be scared of the goop?
Wait.
Should I be...
Oh, I think my cat wants out in a second.
Hold on.
Should I be afraid of the...
I like the decor.
How you doing, pies?
She's just walking around.
Hold on.
Are you okay?
Yeah, let me let her out of my room.
One second.
Come here, girly girl.
You stinky girl.
When she gets too excited, she farts.
She stinks up the place.
Oh, let me let her out.
One second.
Hmm.
One of my cats does the same.
Yeah, cats are so funny.
Hello, chat, and me, though.
I'm telling you, this is like the most romantic.
Oh, oh.
It's just like, it's trying to get closer to me even.
Oh.
I think the goop is flirting with me.
Oh, donk!
What does donk mean?
Donk?
Oh, ding!
Okay, so...
What?
Ding?
Donk.
Ding.
Right, left, straight.
Right?
Left?
Right, left, right?
Right?
Uh, left.
Thank you.
Right?
Left?
Right!
Okay, right- Yippee!
Don't go to the light.
Gosh, that was like really familiar.
You did it.
Yay!
Where's the windfisher?
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Shit.
Wait, there's no music now.
if I'm getting chased or not.
Yippee!
150.
You're being chased.
Keep that blood pumping.
Axe, chop till you drop.
Go.
Here we go.
Love the view.
There's 815 more rooms!
From a week-long trip, week-long!
Wow, we...
Hope you had fun.
Any more... I wonder what the theme is gonna be this time.
We had specimens.
I'm done with jail.
Give me Goop!
Can't help but imagine someone making sugar cookies.
Oh my gosh, Minto...
If I could collaborate with a...
with a bakery, they make Minto cookies.
That'd be so fun.
Okay, we're getting more Goop now.
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, okay, we're getting way more Goop.
Oh, shoot.
Oh gosh.
I heard him.
No.
Oh, we're in a school!
Oh gosh.
How do I know if I'm getting chased?
Oh, locked.
This one's kind of spooky, actually.
Oh, I don't like it.
It's just a flashlight.
Wait, I'm scared.
Ah!
Oh, there's classrooms.
Why is this in Japanese?
Oh my god.
Okay, I can't read.
Huh?
I don't think it...
That's it.
I can't read the first two.
I can read them like su...
Su...
Something.
Maybe?
I can't remember.
I think it's gibberish.
Because it doesn't...
Oh, let's keep going.
I'm hearing things.
Locked.
Is this where I came from?
Or...
Oh, there's a note.
Uh, I can't read it.
Oh, Matsuri never came to class today.
I hope she made it home okay.
Matsuri of Hololife fame!
Matsune Miku!
Uh-oh.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Am I going the right way?
Where's the person?
Oh, this is the first one.
Wait.
Uh, I think I've lost.
Wait, maybe I went down this.
Maybe I'm supposed to go this way.
Oh, there it is.
We're heading.
We're continuing forward, everybody.
Not to worry...
What's that sound?
That's a lie.
Locked.
Three months keeping me alive through my thesis.
Oh my god, Esper, you got this!
You got this.
Oh my gosh, it's doom!
Oh, what's that sound?
What's chasing me?
I don't even know what's chasing me.
Ah!
Why is it gotta be a skelly man that spooks me, man?
What's chasing me?
It sounds lovely though!
Ah!
That's me!
Oh my god, it's getting really loud.
Oh shit, it's getting really...
I think we're okay.
I mean, we're not okay, but...
You know what I mean.
Leave me alone!
Just wants a hug.
Is she gonna chase me forever?
Until 200?
I think we made it.
Oh.
Now there's just another ambiance that's freaking me out.
You sure?
What's that sound?
Just run.
Oh no, 10 more!
10 more!
Until...
A safe room.
Right?
It's every...
I'm going, I'm going.
She just went to Membusha.
Ah!
Hello?
Uh, yes, hello.
Hello, hello.
Hello?
Hello, hello?
Yes.
Hello?
Ah!
Hello.
Oh, wait, they were responding finally!
Oh, shoot.
No.
No!
Who are you talking to?
We made it!
Hang in.
Wait, where's our other poster?
should be a heart rate monitor for this oh my gosh no
monsters and ghosts are just misunderstood they want to be
friends yeah i
wonder whatever happened to that guy that drank the the wine
Whoa.
It's going pretty fast.
So cute.
Wow.
SCP decor.
Uh-oh.
Oh no, not this again.
No, not this room again.
Oh wait.
Oh, oh, I missed it already.
Not this one again.
Wait, which way do I go?
Oh, here's the note.
This is such a surprise that they're...
Oh, wait.
It's the same note as before.
Oh, but it didn't work.
Do I go back?
No.
Maybe I read it and then go to the next one?
Okay.
What the?
Ah, yippee!
Who's sitting in the timeout chair?
Little dummy.
I wonder if this will ever be in order.
Shame corner.
Shame, shame, shame.
Oh, no, all the posters.
Hey, this all looks so familiar.
This all looks so familiar.
The despair chair.
You can't fall down?
Yeah, you can't fall, which is pretty nice, actually.
I guess you can only die.
What the?
What was that?
Oh.
I don't even see it.
Gamers don't look up.
Ah!
Yeah, we've been here before too!
Hmm.
We went to the left on...
Silent Hill?
Oh no.
Maybe I should have gone to the left again.
I don't like this.
I don't like this!
Oh!
Oh my god!
The darkness is slowly consuming us now.
I don't think our rituals will appease it much longer.
How are we supposed to know this would happen?
This is so... feels so Silent Hill 3.
It's not really our fault.
We just did what Mother has told us to do in this sort of
situation.
Oh, broken.
Mother is not pleased with us, but how were we supposed to
know that the girl wasn't pure?
What was that?
Oh, read.
Weird letting.
We're getting all the lore here.
Oh, my goodness.
What did you do to be behind here?
wait which way this way right broken we're getting all the
lore in here oh not in there broke broke oh this one again I
think let's just go straight my vision looks like a QR code
oh my god I know I'm going slow i'm just oh okay uh i think
i need to go fast now i think i need to go fast oh my god
whoa
whoa whoa whoa this is really trippy whoa whoa oh my god my
brain whoa i don't feel like i'm moving at all Ah!
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh.
Why was he right there?
I'm just gonna go to the end.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ah!
We made it.
Whew.
You're safe, I think so.
We'll be safer.
No!
Oh, wait.
Oh, shit.
Never mind.
Let's get it!
Ah!
This is fucked up.
Where's my safe room?
Oh, wait, it's every 50, isn't it?
I'm an idiot!
I...
No!
I missed your bubble!
I can't even get scared by you!
Oh my goodness.
No, not the goop right in front of the door!
I can't even appreciate the rooms.
I've just got to run from goop, guys.
Okay.
All right.
These are all the same.
Oh, gosh.
More goop.
Oh, yeah.
Confusion over fear.
Yeah!
That was unfair.
Oh.
I thought I was safe!
Finally!
You're never safe in the spooky mansion!
Oh my god, oh my god, run, run, run, run.
Oh there's a chair up there for some reason.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao.
And run.
We're almost there, we're almost there!
reels this time for real this time oh oh oh i did that's uh
that's great i shall grant you a gift all your progress so
uh so just keep going
okay you know i can sound like spooky too uh you did you're
doing so great thank you for for playing the game.
Password Pumpkin.
Thanks for playing the game.
We're doing so well.
What's the password for, actually?
What's this, too?
Thanks for the present.
Password pumpkin.
Sike!
I am starting to think she doesn't like me.
Is it because I'm also a ghost?
Do you think she feels a little bit of...
Um...
A little bit of competition?
Perhaps?
Little ghost rivalry?
Yeah, she's threatened by me.
Yeah, she knows.
Thanks for making a video about the Occupy Mid or a pop-up.
I was able to go because you let me know it existed.
Yeah, of course!
Thanks for watching it!
What?
This room stresses me out so much because it's so long, you
know.
Hi, I...
spitter little spitter guy at least it's i was gonna say at
least it's always the same but it just changed what good to
know it changed wait but there's no note there oh this again
all right oh bong bong uh right straight straight Right.
Straight, right, right.
Okay, straight, right.
Straight, right, left.
Straight, right, left!
Bong, bong.
Bing bong.
Ding dong.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's the cat.
cat dogs again.
What if I press it?
It's pretty intimidating.
Should I do it?
Access specimen database.
Dossile.
Total fatality is four!
Method, heart attack.
A cardboard cutout figure that springs out from the walls.
Proved not very effective against healthy subjects.
That guy sucks.
Hold on, I'm turning them.
music down it's too ringy in my ears oh this guy active
total fatalities 137 method physical tearing a mostly
semi-solid base specter that frequently changes matter
states proved very effective against weaker or slower
subjects okay
what is this one infectious buys a test specimen all being
developed this is the spider should prove useful when
released trials have shown it adequately effective to
average subjects.
Oh, we've seen her.
14th century spirit that was contained and relocated here.
Tests have yet to reveal origins, but all relevant
information has been placed into testing chamber.
Proved effective, not greatly more than previous specimens.
We've seen this guy too, right?
He's the one that made the room all crazy.
and fix her.
A creature found inside the church of a small town.
Subjects are lost after contact
with the specimen.
What did I say?
What?
Oh, method!
Commethid?
Commeth of...
Why is it written like that?
That's bad.
The killing is unknown.
Proved extremely effective against subjects with mental
issues or weak wills.
Oh.
Ow!
A wooden-sized life puppet.
Oh, it's also active.
Found floating in a reservoir where a town has once been.
Specimen is active despite appearance and has proved very
effective on subjects who disregard it or have vision
impairments.
Okay.
What do I do with him?
He looks like...
Oh my gosh, he looks like Ben drowned.
wait someone also said bed drown he looks just like the mask
seller oh error dang it
interesting so we have one more guy we need to what is that
oh shoot what what the hell was that i think i'm getting
chased after oh this guy again oh god I've already dealt
with you, please.
I think I go to the right now, right?
Please be right.
Please be correct.
No!
Um.
I'm gonna die.
At least he's slow.
Oh my god, he hits a lot of damage, though.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, shh.
Please.
Yeah.
I can't tell which way it's right.
Yes, okay.
There's a candle there.
Okay, we made it.
My head hurts.
How do you think I feel?
Oh.
Ah!
Yeah!
Not in the green room!
Goop attack!
A goop attack!
Ah!
Is he gone?
I think he's gone.
Oh.
Okay.
We haven't gotten any notes or anything recently.
Like, being like, hey, I'm buddy Joe and I'm lost.
Oh, you guys can't see the room number.
Oh, let me move you let me move you down then.
Sorry, I didn't realize you couldn't see the room number.
Oh wait, hold on.
One more second.
Now you can.
Okay.
I never go this way.
Oh, it's just a loop.
The other way is faster.
Oh.
Hello.
I don't know if you're...
want to look directly into the fan um yes hello um hello uh
yes hello hello hello hello I don't Oh, if you want to look
directly into the fan, um, yes, hello.
Allow, allow.
Hi, allow.
Uh-oh.
This music sounds different.
Just a little.
Oh, Reed.
I think this is my last note.
I'm going to die having never found my escape, but that's
really not my...
Wait, but that's really...
Wait, but really that's not true.
This place was like my escape.
My escape from everything else.
In the end, my death is kind of romantic.
Our romance guy!
This place is finally starting to affect me.
I've seen enough horror movies to know how to survive a
simple ghost or two, but these monsters keep getting faster
and stranger.
Is that a different man?
Unless we're just seeing some of his notes now.
This death is so romantic.
To be or not to be.
Uh-oh.
I'm getting...
Oh, yep.
No!
Not you guys!
Leave me alone!
Goopy ghost, goopy ghost.
Oh, goopy ghost, goopy ghost, goopy ghost, goopy ghost.
Would you guys prefer if I was more goopy or...
How do you like your ghosts?
Moist?
Am I going the right way?
Please say yes.
More wispy.
You're fine the way you are?
You're so sweet!
You accept me as I am!
Yippee!
I wish I could crouch.
Wait, what's it say?
In order to survive this house, I need to keep writing
notes.
Must do everything a central protagonist would and hope this
is one of those stories.
Insert obscure horror reference that no one gets and
misinterprets his instructions somehow.
Is this him?
This is great for me, though.
I think I'm in love with him.
in love with him and now he's a ghost we can be together
this is our true romance i want your loving i want your
romance you and me will write a good romance oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh caught
Spooky mansion, romance, green!
Pink.
Oh shoot.
No.
What's this?
I'm gonna- he's gonna get me!
He's gonna attack me!
Ah!
Oh.
he's gonna get me he's gonna get me
i was not afraid hi of course we accept you as you are
you're the coolest prettiest cutest ghost oh wait paulie
vermont hey ay ay whoosh paulie the only paulie i know know
it's Polly Pocket.
Let's try it again.
Maybe if I read it enough.
Maybe it knows that I'm not reading it.
Shame.
What's this music?
Or rather, ambience.
I am afraid of no sleep.
Read me She'll read.
I've read it before!
That's a mute.
Why is it?
Uh oh.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, this one.
Cool.
Oh, it's locked.
Um.
Can I just run through?
Try this one?
Oh.
Wow!
Oh, I can't...
Wait.
Okay, there we go.
One day a strange merchant came to town.
He sold handmade puppets and trinkets to all the children.
And all the children loved his store and his gifts.
But the town couldn't support his store because of the other
shops were failing.
The other shopkeepers became jealous.
So one night, some of the townspeople took all his puppets
and threw them into the river!
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, we're on the puppet guy.
Pick up the key.
But just afterwards, he came running to the river, crying
and wailing that his children were being drowned.
Ben drowned.
He dove into the river trying to save his possessions.
The townspeople, bitter and still angry, watched him
frantically thrash and dive into the river until he never
came back to the surface of the water.
Ben drowned real!
What do I do with this, with the puppet, though?
It said like I should...
Pay attention to him or something?
Bing bong!
Oh.
Hold on, let's read first.
Years later, oh.
Hold on, maybe it's this one.
Oh.
Although not what they wanted, the shopkeepers were
satisfied.
Years later, the children of the town began to go missing.
And as more and more children disappeared, people began to
find more and more puppets in the forest.
and around the river.
These puppets seemed almost to look like the missing
children sometimes.
What are you saying mint for?
What happened?
Swimming lessons get good, Ben.
Oh!
I'm quite spooked by this.
Oh, he has a key.
I think.
Nope, he has a thing to kill me.
Ah!
Oh,
he looks really sad here.
Ouch!
I'm sorry.
Wait.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh.
Uh, yes, sir.
Oh, shoot.
Yes, sir.
No, sir.
There he is.
Let's keep on going.
Oh, I can open with my back.
Oh, my gosh.
Open.
Nice.
Hello.
Okay.
This is fine.
Yeah, how am I opening them?
I don't know.
Oh gosh, with the goop!
Oh, this is kind of evil, isn't it?
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Ouch!
Oh my god, no way.
Um, it looks... Oh god.
Okay.
We've gone through this room so many times.
times.
Ouch!
Ah!
Okay, so once, once I can't see him anymore, I have to like
find out where he goes.
Okay.
We got this.
Oh, I'm doing my best.
I'm like, I've done this room so many times.
I'm gonna know where he's at, or I'm gonna know how to get
there.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
Um,
maybe this way.
Okay.
It was the other...
Ouch!
I was looking at you, you little bitch.
Don't even.
Don't even act like that to me.
I was giving you all the attention that you desired.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We're fine.
We're fine, everybody.
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, okay.
We're fine.
Ouch.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, we made it!
Oh my god.
Which one's at?
Oh.
You walk into him?
No, I think you can walk into him, right?
It's just...
He's persisted, isn't he?
Oh my god, we did it!
We did it!
Oh, he'll hurt you if you walk into him.
Oh, okay, I'm just kidding them.
Sometimes there's that really loud ambiance.
Hear it?
It's a big old rumbling in my ear.
What is that?
down oh no please oh wait oh i knew it i was like wait i'm
slow why am i slow oh come on oh these guys cheat oh you are
cheating for real oh please be right please be right please
be right yes okay i hear you not the goop ghost
He's using creative mode!
Oh gosh.
I'm just gonna guess.
Oh what?
I think I'm right.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
Too much goop!
I never asked to be a goopy ghost!
Nice.
He's no clipping.
Oh gosh.
Oh my gosh.
Still more.
Not the ectoplasm.
This is a severe case of ectoplasm.
I'll tell you that.
I would never all over the floor.
Maybe once.
I think we're good.
Nice!
I think we're okay?
Actually, I've dodged quite sure.
What are these sounds?
Oh.
This room I got.
We went to the right last time.
Let's go to the left.
The right was really scary, and I didn't like it.
Oh.
Wait a second.
Is this it?
Wait, where's my checkpoint?
Wait, I'm at 350!
Wait, my check...
No way!
Ow!
God!
Oh my god.
Once they start introducing this guy with other characters,
it's gonna be... it's so jover.
Just run!
I'm surprised I lived through that.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, gosh.
No stamina.
He's probably the trickiest in the game.
He is tricky.
Ta-da!
Open him with my cheeks.
I feel like I can't...
I don't even have a chance.
to reach out anymore.
I'm fighting for my afterlife here.
Hey.
Yeah.
You.
Yeah, you.
Hey, Mint.
Look here.
I see you.
Okay.
What are you hiding behind your back there, buddy?
He looks really sheepish.
He's like, Oh, gosh.
You're a golly.
I just want to be friends with you.
I wouldn't hurt you ever.
You're my bestie.
Look at that.
He's shy.
Um, yeah, so?
Me too.
I actually don't know if I can fall into the goo.
I would really not like to find out.
Where are you?
Did he give up?
Oh, is this room again?
Alrighty, let's go right.
Bing bong.
Left.
Left straight.
Dang.
Left.
Straight.
Oh.
Yee-bee!
I like the pink rooms Back rooms, yellow rooms, pink rooms
Green rooms Mint gaming Yeah
Orange rooms?
No, I love orange My Oshi's color is orange Okay
Actually, I feel like I have an Oshi that is every color at
this point.
My Oshis are the dang rainbow at this point.
Quite the long room.
A true DD.
I know.
But usually, I pick...
Usually my favorite members are blue.
Your Oshi is Garfield and yours isn't?
Whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, no.
Am I being chased through here?
Please say no.
Is Sonic Yeroshi?
Hmm.
When I was a kid, I used to like Tails the most.
Oh, gosh.
So...
The Smurfs?
I love...
Blue people.
Base Tails and Joyer.
I always thought he was so cute.
There's different kinds of ghosts.
I wonder what kind...
You are, Mint.
Revenant, Poltergeist, Wraith, perhaps?
I'm a U-Day.
I'm a vengeful ghost.
Uh-oh.
What's that sound?
What is this?
What's chasing after me?
Is this the girl?
Wait, what is this?
Oh, is this room again?
Oh, we already did this, right?
Is there anything new?
Next!
Specimen 7.
Did I even miss this before?
Active.
Specimen is constantly changing form and attributes
depending on subject's personality, but most common form
resembles a wall of moving anatomy.
symbols only effective on subjects with past trauma or a
history of psychological issues we outer wild absorption a
floating figure that appeared in a test chamber a few years
after it was filled with what was believed to be and just to
just be unusually violent deer specimen seems to engulf
subjects and absorb them into its torso region.
Proved extremely effective on violent subjects.
Here.
It'll let me modify it eventually, right?
Oh, there it'll go.
Games!
Shikano-kano-kano-kano-kano-kano peeka no no no no no no no
no just three more three more maybe hopefully
Oh.
Oh yeah
Ah!
400!
Yippee!
You can do it!
We can help Papa John's!
Oh, gosh.
Checkpoints.
So now the checkpoints are after 100?
I feel like they should have changed that after 500.
for it.
Papa John is making me want pizza.
Okay, you guys, I gotta go to the bathroom real quick.
I gotta go use a little ghosty's room.
Is that okay?
I do have some ectoplasm that must you know what?
I'm gonna quit while I'm ahead of the sake.
Anyway, I'm gonna I'll be right back.
Don't go anywhere.
I'm Thanks for all the super chats!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
I
swallowed my spit wrong.
Anyway.
Down.
Let's go down.
Did you wash your hands?
Of course I did!
Oh, I'm taking a sippy of my tea.
Oh my gosh, we're almost halfway there.
How long does it usually take to beat this game?
I feel like...
Did you save?
I did, right?
I did save, right?
Ooh!
We're just in a big old dungeon.
I'm gonna go down this way.
Uh-oh.
Maybe I...
Maybe I won't go down that way.
About three hours.
Oh, why?
Mmm.
Hey!
Toast!
Ah.
What's the DLC like?
Is it the same thing but a hospital?
What was that sound?
Whoa, what is this?
Threshold of consciousness.
Oh,
it's more exploratory.
Here I go!
Oh!
Little cat.
Cute!
Oh, talk.
Well, hello there.
Are you lost, little one?
This place can help you.
those who are ready, but expect turmoil more than you are
used to.
Oh.
What's that mean?
Bye-bye, Q-bye.
Oh.
Oh, there's the door.
Yep.
Where the heck am I?
Oh.
Okay.
What that mean?
Is this the airport?
Oh my gosh, you guys!
I have a hand cam on Wednesday.
Oh, but my nails...
My nail, another nail of mine just broke!
Oh, do I want to touch...
I don't want that to touch me, alright?
Two sides of the same coin.
Tell me your shape.
Oh.
What does that, what does that mean?
Wow.
Oh, it's pointing at me.
My nails, my nails are not very nice.
I think I, you know, I'm a ghost.
It's like, usually I wear gloves anyway so you can see me
better, so I'm not transparent, but I might just have to,
I'm worried about building it with gloves.
gloves on.
So basically I'm building like this bookshelf thing.
And it's like, it looks like...
Oh, wasn't I just here?
Oh.
Diorama?
Yeah!
Put on your mask.
Oh, follow the group.
Be who you are.
Let's go Oh god, oh god, it's an office.
Oh my god.
The mask you wear serves its purpose well.
But be careful not to lose yourself.
But my nails have been breaking so much this week.
I don't know why.
If you would like to name a kitten?
A little black cat?
Mint!
Hmm.
Salem?
Liquid?
Oh, a note.
Well, I still haven't died, so it appears I might be the
protagonist.
But I'm not entirely sure.
I hope I'm not some side character that leaves notes for
pointless exposition.
Also, I found a strange computer that gives the descriptions
of the monsters.
And it seems like they're all called effective based on how
many people they kill.
Yeah, I read that too.
This guy is me.
Shalashaska.
Shalashaska is a great name.
That's the... Wait, there wasn't blood here on the brain
before, was there?
Uh-oh.
I think Shalashaska's a great name for a cat.
Let's go to the left.
Oh, shoot.
No!
Oh.
These places are like safe zones, kinda.
Oh!
I'm seeing everything, little cat.
I've seen everything.
That doesn't look good.
Maybe I shouldn't keep talking to this guy.
Knowing your shadow can greatly help you, but be ready to
see what you'd rather not be.
Oh!
Whoa!
Uh-oh.
I don't wanna know!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I don't wanna know.
Whoa, I like the music here though.
Oh my gosh.
Was that a funky man?
Oh shit, oh shit!
I don't know what's going on!
My mind is broken!
Oh shoot.
I can't tell what's going on.
Just...
I'm just running.
Can't tell.
Just run?
Oh I am!
Oh god.
Please be correct.
Yeah!
No!
I like the BGM.
It's kind of funky.
I like it.
I don't know if the guy on the wall is evil or what, but I'm
not sticking around to find out.
Ooh.
This guy is spread eagle over here.
Like, come on.
Oh.
Hello, hello.
Hello.
Alright.
Oh, it's this place again.
Um, right.
Oh, uh, left.
Straight.
Shala Shaska it is.
She meows to it.
Left.
Straight.
Right.
Straight, right, straight.
Dang it.
Straight, right, left.
Oh my gosh, straight, right, right.
Straight?
Straight, right, right.
Oh my gosh, the guy with this banana!
He's back.
Oh.
I think the effectiveness of the specimens is also somehow
related to the souls of the people they kill somehow.
Anyways, I'm still alive and strong.
But I feel like the most inmost cave of my journey lies
ahead.
I wonder what the antagonist will look like.
I hope they're cute.
Summarize the cat, putting on personas is useful, but don't
get too absorbed.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Oh my gosh, what's this?
It's getting so loud.
Whatever this ambiance is.
I'm just gonna keep running.
I hope the antagonist is cute too.
Whoa, this is such a cool effect.
It looks like the candle was blown out and there's the smoke
from it.
Dr. Squiggles!
Welcome to Membuship.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god.
I didn't expect a toast.
there.
Oh, the in-game cat.
Why are we talking about multiple cats?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Give me out of here.
Oh, yeah.
Hello, Fint Manton.
That's not my name.
Thanks, Marth.
Welcome to Membo.
Oh, ship.
Thank you.
No!
Oh!
I wish I could jump.
This guy sucks.
Thanks for the super chat!
Where are you going to sleep?
Good night!
I'm running.
Oh my god.
I thought I might be safe.
Nope, I'm running slowly.
Oh my goodness.
Two in a row!
This is messed up.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop.
Oh, my God.
I went the wrong way.
Shoot.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Oh, gosh.
Hey, yeah.
Welcome back, Marikami.
Yeah, I can't do it.
Locked.
I got jump scared and it was locked.
I think the guy's not chasing after me anymore, though.
Whoa, this is a very narrow hallway.
Specimens?
What is this?
Oh, cool.
Hmm.
Maybe I should have explored it.
Ah!
Oh my god, I forgot what it was.
Oh god, I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna die!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please,
please, please,
she's cheating, she's cheating, she's cheating, she's
cheating, she's cheating, she's cheating, she's cheating,
she's cheating, I mean, if I was a ghost, I would tell, I
mean, I am a ghost, but, if I could, I would!
Miss specimen, I'm on your side!
Aren't you already dead?
It's not fair.
Games never recognize my deadness.
They always assume that.
Ah!
That the person playing is alive!
They always assume.
And you know what assuming does.
If I could, I would.
It's true!
If I could, I would!
Yeah, assuming turns you into an ass.
You become a butt.
Let's go to the right.
Like a donkey.
Oh, this one's new.
Actually, it doesn't even give me the option to go to the
other side.
Oh, no.
Oh, this is the long one.
Just kidding.
Thanks for the page.
I see that as a win-a-ass, a win-win.
Don't get it.
Doesn't that mean I get a dragon GF?
Um, put some respect on that title.
It's a dragon wife.
He has kids with her.
Donke has children with the dragon!
Good for him.
Shrek 5 hype?
Oh yeah, let's go check this out now.
Oh, why did I check it out?
Why did I check it out?
Oh, oh, oh, we...
I made it!
You just keep on going, don't you?
Well, the next door has been fixed up for you.
So enjoy and keep moving on.
Little fleshy eye one.
That's not me at all.
I'm not fleshy.
I don't know the last time I've had flesh.
Spooky.
We're halfway there.
Cheese!
First pumpkin, then cheese.
Dang.
Are you sure it's out of order?
Wait, so we're not going down anymore?
I can't believe we're halfway there, you guys.
Oh, just kidding.
Uh-oh, now some doors are fake.
I just realized that I never had a mentor figure trial or
leaving.
home scene.
That means the story isn't following the archetypes to make
me a traditional hero, which means I can be killed off.
Well, it was nice for at least a little while at least.
Oh, room 51.
52!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Can I go back?
I can't!
She's!
She's cheating!
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no!
Turn off, oh no.
Wait a second.
Oh, they can come through.
Even though the room is really skinny, they can still come
through.
Oh, yep.
No way.
Cannot release twice.
Exit through Express.
Express turn on!
Yuppie!
Cheese game!
Oh.
Cheese game.
Right!
Straight!
Oh.
Right.
Straight.
What?
Straight?
Right?
Left.
Oh, come on.
These guys are such a pain in my...
Oh.
Side.
What's that music?
Uh-oh.
This is a new room.
Why do I hear, like, a music box?
Oh, gosh.
There's so much here!
Unfair.
The goopy!
These guys are everywhere!
I hear.
Well, that's a new one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Let's get out of here.
Let's skedaddle-addle.
This- This place needs a maid!
I would never keep my mansion looking so horrible!
Do you guys hear the music?
I can't tell if it's ambiance or...
Something.
What was that?
Purple!
Whoa, this room is really purple.
Wow, wee.
Scream lag, the stream.
There's lag.
I wonder if maybe it's the YouTube side.
The grimace room?
Okay, last time...
I don't remember.
Let's go this way.
Oh, shoot.
Why does this keep happening to me?
Is he gonna get me?
Okay.
I'm reading the note.
Your influence and inspiration will never leave me.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
No!
Must I get caught once?
Oh, this was such a surprise that there would be another
entry, not another actual entry.
Blah, blah.
Read it with feeling.
This was such a surprise.
Okay, let's just go get got.
You guys are gonna scream.
Ready?
Scree!
Oh.
You guys are gonna scream.
Scree!
I actually don't mind that room, though, now.
because it's guaranteed, basically, to be safe.
It's just a guy that comes after me.
Oh, okay.
This suspiciously long hallway.
Okay.
That got me.
Oh!
Oh, it's this guy.
Open.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Open, open.
Oh, gosh.
I hate these rooms with him.
They're really hard.
These ones are not so bad.
Wait, weren't we just down there below?
That's so funny.
Oh, now we're back down here below.
He's just so goofy.
Yeah, he doesn't really scare me.
Oh, gosh.
He just, uh...
He's just frustrating to deal with because he's like one of
those types of enemies, you know?
Every horror game has this enemy.
Ooh, the music's getting freaky, though.
He's very fast.
He is, he is.
You have to be really on your toes with this guy.
Whoa!
Oh.
Whoa.
Oh, I'm in.
I'm a peasant man.
Whoa.
What is this?
For a while, I thought I had really escaped this place.
But despite the trees and flora, I think this is actually
just another room I did.
Oh, oh, I room.
Oh, I did however find deer.
So I might at least get to eat.
They make some strange sounds, though.
What did they say about these guys?
Do I just have to run from them?
Oh, gosh.
Run from the deer?
The violent deer?
Oh.
Can I take that?
Extra dimensionally choppy.
What do I do?
Oh, I chopped down the door.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Ow!
Whoa.
Freaky.
Oh, another place with, like, rooms and stuff.
Any lore?
Yeah!
This one?
Locked.
Um.
Oh!
I got a key.
I didn't even notice it before.
Unless it wasn't there before.
I don't know.
This nexus specimen is dangerous.
Yeah.
Yeah, I don't like him.
Oh god.
Okay.
Yes, dear.
No, dear.
What are you saying?
I'm cutting you off.
You're too slow.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Out of my way, please!
Oh god.
Oh.
Out of my way, please!
Join us!
Cutting you off, man.
I'm not listening.
I don't want anything to do with your weird cult, okay?
My what?
What'd you say?
You have to speak up!
There should be a mod that replaces what they say with that
song.
The Deer Club.
Probably wants to give hugs.
I think of the deer that are in Nara that, like, get
aggressive with you and you'll try to feed them.
Do I sell my axe?
I do!
Very nice.
Ah!
Oh, I was like, Huh?
Okay.
Alrighty.
I haven't started any new anime this season.
Um.
But it seems like there's a lot of really great stuff this
season.
So.
I should get on it.
It's just been kind of too...
Too busy.
I think I won't be able to really watch too much until like
probably I don't know
I don't want to wait until the season's over but because
then you know it's always harder to get motivated to watch
something once it's over like it's easier to watch it week
by week oh shoot I was like am I slow or what no more goop
say it with me no more goop no more goop oh my god
no more goop oh shoot i have to go this way hit the goop i
can't unless i can oh
my gosh there's even more Goop!
Non-stop Goop.
I think the goop is tasty.
Yeah, it really looks like it would taste like a green
Gatorade.
Or do you know the yellow Gatorades?
Pick one.
I don't like this.
I feel like one is going to lead to room 600 and one isn't.
One is going to lead to a save point and one is not.
Okay.
I need my need my need my catch a tiger by the toe whippy
hollers let him go my mom said to pick the very best one and
you are it
Pillar make like a tree and die coming this fall
We're going down, down, and we're running around.
Sugar word, don't, going down, screaming.
I'll be your number one with a mullet.
A mother god complex, cock it and pull it.
Ooh, starting off very exciting.
Endless hallway.
Okay.
Another endless hallway.
Mint out, boy.
Good night, Mint.
Good night.
Did you guys have a good weekend?
Did you guys have fun?
Oh, I still have my axe even.
That's exciting!
I like miserable weekend next to awesome weekend.
Meh.
Before you know it, it'll be the weekend.
Again?
Oh.
Day 2.
Food supply depleted.
Water supply at 30%.
Mental health deteriorating.
Leaving notes behind to help others and mark where I've
been.
in this mansion?
How would I do it?
Oh.
You know what they say.
Just be yourself.
Oh.
I feel like I'm in a different game.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
What do they use to lock the doors in here?
Spookies.
Whoa.
This old place is somehow even worse than the new GL labs.
Although it seems to have been constructed with a much
larger budget than the new lab.
Nothing works quite right.
I can see why it was abandoned so quickly.
I wonder if there really is anything here worth salvaging.
Beep boop.
Oh, we have some light.
Oh.
Oh, guys.
Dead space time.
Yeah, right.
GL Labs.
Let me guess, like the power only works for a certain amount
of time or something crazy.
Oh, oh no, I knew it!
No, why did I have to call it?
Oh my god.
I don't like this.
This is...
What is that?
How many rooms am I getting through here?
615?
Oh, 6.
Spooky just said that there were things we needed to salvage
from this place.
I'm starting to worry that a loose specimen may be included
in the list of things for us to retrieve.
The power just shut off again.
Is everything broken in here?
My room didn't...
My room number didn't change at all.
or did it i don't think it did though oh there's another
note i don't know what to do i can't think well i feel
strange i'm hiding from that thing i feel like something is
growing on my skin i can't seem to tear it off fast enough
and i'm losing a lot of blood what is going on here
uh-oh you have to keep it close close it becomes something
else when it gets too far away outrun.
Keep it close?
Oh my god.
What the hell is that?
Wait, keep it close.
What the?
Oh, that thing!
Wait.
I don't know how to do it.
Ah!
I'm gonna die.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh,
it's on me!
Oh, we're gaining health.
I think I can't run.
I think I have to walk.
Okay, keep it close.
Keep it close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come here, baby.
Come here, baby, girl.
Hey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Okay, okay.
Oh, how did I live?
Oh my god.
Oh no!
No!
I was walking!
You're just too slow!
We're walking.
I'm walking too fast, apparently.
Oh my god.
When this gets too far away, he turns into a bug monster.
Excuse me.
Yip, yip, yip.
Come on.
Come on, come on, come on.
Yip, yip, yip, yip.
Yip, yip.
Yip, yip, yip.
yep yep yep yep yep yep it reminds me of something from like
stranger things yeah i'm taking my pet alien for a walk love
that movie teeth yep oh nice long hallway for us to travel
down you and me buddy yep oh i love you yeah became like a
little head god it was first a giant head then became a
hugger just like a cat yeah just like a cat oh my god okay
oh my god really not the time toast
yeah okay i don't mind this one so much it just makes it
hard for us to um you know for us to um speed through these
rooms but that's okay there's always time for toast It makes
it a little hard for us to go through these rooms really
quickly, but that's okay.
Friend-shaped.
You guys kept mentioning that all these ghosts or all these
monsters and stuff just want to hug.
And this is the first time I've really felt invited.
You know?
This is the first time I've ever felt invited.
The monster that was inspired by the movie The Thing, which
also inspired the very known game I've seen.
Oh, wait, this monster?
Oh, this monster was inspired by the thing.
I can see it.
I love that movie.
Which I did know inspired Among Us.
Oh, we're here.
End of.
Nine?
Take the dead to take the dead to.
Take the dead to take the dead.
to take the dead to take the dead to take the dead to take
the dead to take the dead to take the dead to take the dead
the dead to take the guy yeah a form changing creature that
is believed to be an extraterrestrial though It was not
officially proven.
Proved very effective on most subjects, but deemed too
difficult to contain.
The specimen broke out of its containment area due to
frequent electrical malfunctions.
245!
That was almost me.
Not gonna lie.
Where are we taking them?
I don't know.
This one, though, it has zero deaths.
Zero fatalities, I mean.
Hmm.
I'm afraid of no ghost.
Can I...
Can you change the house layout now?
Cool.
Take the dead to take the dead to...
What's that sound?
Oh, it sounds kind of wet.
Like a...
Sounds like that.
It would be kind of embarrassing to be the first kill.
I know, right?
Oh gosh.
It's really rumbly.
Someone's hungry!
Hmm.
Not me though, you sure?
Virgil?
Did you eat?
Long hallway.
Oh goodness.
Ah!
Oh my gosh!
No!
Please!
Ben...
I wonder what the line of...
He's like, you!
You!
He's pointing at me like, you!
Eww!
Why don't I get my hands on?
Ow!
Oh gosh!
Ah, Ben!
I'm sorry, man.
I'm gonna start over.
Let's start over.
We're cool.
We're chill.
Oh.
Eww!
Oh gosh.
Like I went the wrong way.
Good old Ben.
Really?
I don't know.
That's a bit of a...
I don't know if good is...
Right.
Oh my gosh.
Oh,
we get a little bit of a theramine action or something.
I want to learn the theramine so bad.
If I did a theramine learning stream, would you guys listen?
Yeah.
We can make some spooky Halloween music or something.
something?
Ben.
Oh my god.
Fidya!
That was so close.
Oh my goodness.
Hell yes.
I can actually do it with my mouth.
Can you ax him?
Oh my god.
Hi.
Oh.
Ben drowned!
Yeah!
You can hit the puppet with the axe.
Yeah, take that.
Bozo?
It's alright if your name is Ben.
Oh, he's gone.
Yippee!
Pharamone.
Srim.
Like, sense?
Green.
It ain't easy being green.
Okay.
Stop killing Bennett's son.
He needs to stop hurting me then.
I'm so glad that this game eventually has health recover.
And like a pretty quick pace too.
It's very forgiving.
Oh, this room again.
Left!
Right!
Straight!
Right.
Left.
Oh shoot.
Wait, it was right.
Right.
and straight no right right left and left the silliest
silliest march walk ever
you're like hopping on one foot at one point doing splits
yeah exactly
I like how they're I'm so curious about the lore for this
game.
I want more.
I want more lore.
Give me more notes.
Give me more floating skull heads.
All the lore is in the DLC.
Is that the hospital one?
There's two DLC focused on the lore?
Two?
What a suspiciously long haul.
Wait.
Oh, and the dollhouse.
I don't know.
The dollhouse.
Locked.
Okay.
Rude.
I can't believe they just have random doors that are locked
like that.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no.
This is the girl, isn't it?
No!
Ah!
Boo ice cream!
Do, do, do, do.
Oh, it's the girl, it's the girl.
No, no.
No, girl, run away.
Run away from the girl.
Run away from girl.
She's like, don't you want a ghost girlfriend?
She is desperate woman.
I, I mean...
I want any more!
I'm not ready for combat!
Please!
Oh my god, the music's so loud.
It feels like she's right behind me.
It feels like she's breathing down my neck.
Girls have good hours!
Minto running away from a girl?
That's a first.
She's just a intimidated she's like oh lovely ghost girl
let's beat besties and i'm like really i don't i don't know
you oh my god no way she's so fast oh my god she's so fast
is it because she can go through walls i'm like letting my
i'm like using every inch of my oh my gosh what my stamina
when i get it back i use it she's gonna get you no oh we
made it good job guys we're at oh my gosh we're at 6 69 nice
Shoof Six Oh Mr. Brain We meet again The Pinkie and the
Brain And Larry The Pinkie and the Brain and Larry One is a
genius The other is insane Then there's Larry Their
laboratory mice I don't know what the rest is Do you guys
remember that episode?
There's an episode of Pinky and the Brain where...
Yeah, I didn't...
I think what had happened was the place, I think Warner
Brothers had the show or whatever.
And they were like, hey, you should add another mouse.
They were like, no, it's Pinky and the Brain.
You don't need a third mouse.
And they're like, no, add a third mouse to your show.
They were like, okay.
and so they like out of pure spite they added the most
annoying character and then had him ruin the iconic opening
of the show so oh no and so it's just it's like the my
favorite example of what's the word compliant malicious
compliance and then nobody liked Larry enough to keep him
in.
Wow, thank you for the pink!
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
No!
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh gosh, please, please, please!
At least there's only one of them, but...
Oh my god, no.
Please, please, please.
No!
They were like, at a human and they put in...
Oh, okay.
Hold on.
I can't...
Read right now.
I'm getting attacked on every angle.
Hold on.
Oh, shoot.
There's two of them.
I love malicious compliance so much.
Me too.
I'm getting goop to you guys.
Okay.
Oh, this guy, this is a disgusting, this is why I'm a ghost
maid, because ghosts like this exist.
What do you think the maid cafe looks like after a days of
ghostly patrons, right?
Oh, awful.
These are the worst types of customers.
Oh, I think we're good now.
Oh, hippie.
Okay.
Maybe just a few more.
I can't tell anymore.
I don't know when the game is gonna troll me.
Oh, wow.
Are ghost girls a type of slime girl?
There might be like a ghosty slime girl.
I don't...
Hmm.
You're making me question my existence.
You're making me question things.
But I only want them to goop if they're hot.
And I'm trying not to be judgmental, but this guy is just
overdoing it, you know?
Yippee!
Axe!
Ha!
300 left.
Ooh.
Smash!
Boo!
Thanks for the five gifting!
Uh oh.
What does that sound?
I'm just gonna keep going.
What is that sound?
Our ghost slime's extra goopy.
Not extra.
If you're extra goopy, you might want to consult your
physician.
You might want to go to the boo-spital.
Oh!
Why is it...
What the heck is this?
Taste the beef!
I'm in a...
I'm in a liminal space?
Um...
It's broken.
Nasty.
Reed?
Oh!
Well, I broke my one rule today.
The management doesn't give out actual lunch break, so I
can't go anywhere.
And they won't allow outside food here.
I mean, they actually screamed at the last customer who did
that.
Anyway.
I had a burger.
It wasn't bad, and I don't feel sick.
Uh, and it has something, something.
I'm scared.
Broken.
Hold it?
Oh, but everybody can go into the ladies room.
I was anxious getting a job here at first, but it seems like
things are getting better.
This chain is really expanding, which is a shock because
just last week I heard the company was going broke.
Every day more and more people show up to eat here.
Something still sets me off about the place, and it's food,
though.
So I'm going to try to not eat anything from here.
Oh, I'm reading him out of order.
Oopsie.
Locked.
Oh.
Today was a weird day.
Men don't need to use restrooms.
number of orders continues to rise as it has been but i
don't know about the number of people today i saw someone
use the drive-through and order a lot of food for one person
and then about 10 minutes later they were back they ordered
the same exact meals and then they left again then another
10 minutes they were back again maybe they're just
delivering food for a party or hotel but it worries me for
some reason 100 proof
and so now they ate it we read that in the bathroom
Fun rules!
100% brief.
I don't want to leave you.
What's in here though?
We could go in.
Put your shoes away.
Wait, should we go in?
No screams.
Look out for snakes.
No alcohol, no diving, no hiding.
We will find you.
Look out for snake!
Note on the floor?
This is strange.
I had a dream last night about this restaurant.
I know I was here, but I also felt like I was in another
place at the same time.
Everything looked so wrong.
Nothing was the right size and I kept hearing these strange
animal noises.
Almost like wailing.
I guess I feel guilty for eating that burger the other day.
Also today I saw that man again.
The one who kept ordering every 10 minutes.
But, oh, oh, this time he never even left the parking lot.
He just got his meal parked and then got back in line.
He must have done it at least 8 times before he left.
I'm scared.
Should I go in?
I'm so scared.
I'm scared.
It was fat, man.
Go in?
Guys, if I die in here, though, I think that's pretty bad.
Oh.
I don't think I'm crawling.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Metal Gear Pro- Uh...
Uh...
Oh!
Key!
Maybe I had to come in here for the key to leave.
Oh!
I did it!
But I got the key!
This is I- uh, I got the key!
Um, is there another key?
Wrong door.
This is the bathroom?
Oh, no, that was broken.
Uh, oh, this room!
Oh, oh, I don't like this at all.
I don't like this at all.
I don't like this at all!
Ah!
Um, say it?
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna run.
Oh!
I don't understand this guy.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Oh, I had to.
Die it, maybe?
Or is this part of the game?
Oh no.
I don't have my axe anymore.
Did I die?
Is this...
Is this what happens when you die?
Oh...
Get beefed.
Uh...
Hello?
Beef.
No!
It was an actual death!
Oh, that's...
Oh,
he hides doors, huh?
If I continue...
Oh!
Honestly, impressive you made it that far without losing.
From 700.
700 with no deaths is really good, really?
That's good, I guess.
Save more often.
What are you talking about?
You can only save at the checkpoint.
You can only save at the jack boy.
Oh, there's even more here now.
This guy.
Floating red figure that was found inside a secret area
below a large abandoned corporate office was owned by a
restaurant franchise.
The specimen is extremely violent.
It also seems to leave the house at will despite various
containment methods.
vanish on contact with specimen but sometimes remain remains
of the victims have been found inside the testing chamber
days later proved not effective as victim souls do not
remain after contact and 12 what is this one an old
Victorian mansion that seems to build itself around its
environment the specimen oh my gosh it's uh that one Stephen
King book um uh rose rose Rose, mansion, rose, red, rose,
rose red, yes!
Rose red, the Arby's demon.
The specimen sometimes chooses a host to possess and uses
them to attack the subject with various means depending on
the host's characteristics.
Not much is known about the origin of the mansion, but signs
occasionally show an earlier massacre or tragedy has taken
place within the mansion.
very effective but varies itself too often to be a reliable
method of extraction so that's what they call it extraction
eh boom
well we're back here i can't even tell so the the demon guy
the rb's demon um, hides doors.
The mansion is a clock tower reference.
You know, I never played clock tower either.
Such a fake horror fan.
Really?
Double in a roll?
Arby's Eamon does hide doors.
Okay.
So I could have made it out, maybe.
Dang it.
I think I went the wrong way.
Yep.
Hmm.
I'm just a horror enthusiast.
There, oh, sorry.
There's like, I'm kind of picky about what kind of horror I
like, though.
Typically.
I'm not just like, you know, like to me...
Oh!
Remember this place?
To me, like, you know, Resident Evil Institute.
stuff i don't ever really consider horror maybe seven oh i
guess we have to come here don't we dang it do i have to
read the notes again
resident evil's more action than horror yeah exactly i
always thought that too
okay silent hill i liked oh broken i'm just reading I'm
reading them just in case, uh...
Oh, there's the note.
I'm reading them just in case, uh...
There we go.
I have to.
Any upcoming horror movies you're excited for?
Um... I just watched Red Letter Media's review on long
lengths, I think it was.
Which, um, seemed okay.
Oh, I just realized you can't sprint in here.
Okay, good to know.
Long legs is good.
Just gonna go the same way I did before.
Oh.
Where's the key?
Oh, there it is.
Ping pong.
The witch.
Oh yeah, that one, I like that one.
one actually I thought I don't mind slow like atmospheric
horror you know okay so this guy he hides the doors he hides
door this is gonna be tricky I'm only at 710 though so if I
lose 10 levels I guess it's not I guess it's not the end of
the world the end of the world oh god I'm scared though
That's so unfair!
Yeah!
And he flies.
Oh, I just saw it disappear.
Oh, interesting.
Oh my god, get out of my way.
This is now not the time.
Oh my god, he's gonna fly straight towards me!
I have no stamina!
Oh gosh, I don't know which way to go.
I'm gonna risk it.
This way?
Please be right.
It was not right.
Ah!
I'm so tense right now.
Okay.
Oh my god, thank goodness.
He's only...
Oh, is there one here?
Yes.
I was gonna say he's only hidden one door.
But there he goes.
Hiding a second one!
Oh yeah, yeah.
Oh no, this is the really long room.
No, this is evil.
Oh my god.
I thought he was done chasing me for a second.
This is really evil to put me in a room with this guy.
Come on.
In this room?
With this guy who can float?
Oh.
Can I attack him?
I wonder.
Hey.
Quit bugging me!
I'm so tense.
Oh my, oh my god.
Don't just...
Don't just disappear the door.
All of a sudden.
Oh, wow.
While I was in the middle of...
Oh, my god.
Please.
Leave me alone!
I'm glad I'm seeing them before he...
Before he...
Disappears them.
Yoooo!
I'm so tense!
Wait, am I actually free?
We did it!
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna have carpal tunnel from this.
Oh my goodness!
Yeah!
Oh!
Okay, hold on, I really need to stretch my hand.
Oh, it wasn't my mouse that I was death gripping.
It was the, it was the wastum to move.
I was just like, trying to, I was trying to run as fast as I
could.
How are you doing, buddy?
Now you have the meat.
Oh.
R.B.'s.
Clanging onto that W.
I know.
I really was.
Oh.
Day 3.
Illusinations are manifesting at increasing intervals.
The cause is probably...
I missed day 1, didn't I?
The cause is probably sleep deprivation or a gas that is
being pumped into the rooms.
I have Not yet been injured, so I don't think the cause is a
brain injury or blood clot.
Oh, look at you, show off.
Has Rich Everett's laugh ever scared your cat?
I don't think so.
Meets.
Why?
Are you speaking from experience?
Oh, we're back here again.
Game room.
Not the shamed chair this time, though.
Yon got me to run.
Uh, Yon?
Run.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop.
Oh, the side.
Nah.
744.
Oh.
Hallucinations are a matter of...
Day four.
I'm starting to lose track of time.
The battery on my phone became very low, so I delegated it
to save...
Delegated it to save...
I'm delegated to save it in the case I find an exit.
Three month three.
Thanks for three months!
Oh, no.
Oh, it's this room!
Okay, one.
We don't read it.
Don't care.
This guy is gonna come after us.
Now, are you guys ready to scream?
Woo!
Oh.
What?
Okay.
Collagen.
I hope I said your name right.
Thanks for joining!
Left.
Right.
Straight.
Go left Straight Straight Straight again Oh Straight Left
Right Straight Straight Left Straight Straight Straight
Straight!
Left!
Oh, oh, I forgot.
Okay, never mind.
I was like, oh, I forgot.
Oh!
You'll need unlimited salmon out of race to the end.
The final stretch!
Password cake.
Oh, hi.
Hi.
Thank you.
I think?
She actually gave me a gift!
Unlimited stamina.
Also, Colleague, thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Does it, like, take away my health or something?
Wait.
Why is my stamina not working anymore?
Wait, I have unlimited stamina, but I can't run.
Uh-oh.
Oh my god, no way.
I can't run.
I can't run!
Oh.
She's so evil!
She made sure your stamina doesn't run out.
Oh my god.
Wait, is it like this the rest of the game?
No.
And with the goop monster, this is so evil.
No, no, no.
With the goop monster, please.
Please, please, please.
Please, please.
Oh my gosh.
This is so evil.
Oh my god, what is that noise?
What was that?
Don't.
I forgot to turn the volume back down.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh, I got it back.
Wait.
When did it come back?
Seven is yellow again.
She's so rude.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I really thought I would be like that for the rest of the
game.
760 sucks
Day 5 I can't remember Why did I come here?
Was there ever a purpose?
I believe death is steadily approaching me now The
hallucinations can hurt me I'm out of provisions And I'm
suddenly having violent heart palpitations Rutt roll Rutt
roll Get stumped.
7.69.
Not the palpitations.
Emperor palpitators.
Emperor.
Oh!
Avid reader.
I got a...
These are their stories.
That was the achievement.
Day 7.
I can't tell the real from Unreal anymore.
My limbs refuse to move the way I want them to.
I feel like I'm wadding it.
a deep river that is always flowing against my direction now
i will lay down and let the river flow over me i will let it
guide me to its end i know where i'm going anyway this place
this entire place is just a gyrating screaming rock in the
vastness of an infinite kingdom i'm going to rest now i'll
be watching over you super mint ten mint nendo welcome to
membership thank you They're watching over me.
I have a guardian angel.
Wait.
What's this one again?
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, shoot.
I don't remember.
Uh, uh.
Oh, oh, okay.
I know.
Ah!
Oh, I know!
Beef demon, beef demon.
And we've got the beef!
We've got the meats, we've got the meats, we've got the
meats.
Yeah, it's kind of, kind of icky though that his description
doesn't say that he can get rid of the doors.
You know what I mean?
But I guess if you, I think I, I think I got really unlucky
in that I didn't have a room where I could see that he would
do that.
You know what I mean?
Oh, we made it.
I just kept running.
So, so I like had no idea.
I just thought it was a dead end.
I thought it was supposed to happen that way.
I smell like beef.
788, baby.
That was unlucky.
Yeah, I think so, too.
And then, you know, when I'm running away, I don't really...
I can't...
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Wait, what is this one?
Is this the...
Oh my god.
Oh, it's this guy!
Oh, no, no, no, no!
It's this guy!
Okay, never mind.
We're good.
Come on, baby.
Come on, baby, baby.
Come on.
The thing.
It's the thing, yeah.
We don't mind this guy.
Come on, baby.
Yeah.
Oh.
This way.
Uh-oh.
Not this way!
Rude.
Rude, rude, rude, rude, rude.
Yep.
Oh my god, no, no!
No!
How did I get too far away from you, huh?
The rude sandstorm.
Boop!
Oh!
We made it!
Oh my gosh, 800!
Yippee!
We're going down, down!
Sugar, we're going down!
Sugar, we're going down, screaming!
Number one with the mole.
A number one cockpit, cock it and bullet.
Minto Gaming!
Yippee!
Oh, Kai.
Left, left, left, right, left.
800.
This is a new room.
Interesting.
Oh, no!
No!
I'm trapped in the goop.
Trapped in the... O's O's?
No, I'm trapped in the goop.
These goop guys are too nasty.
Wow!
Remilia, Sama?
Is this Castlevania?
I like this.
Yeah, this is new.
This mansion is strange.
I think the bricks and wood are actually just painted on.
Everything still feels kind of fake.
Also, I keep hearing movement and voices below me.
Maybe other survivors are hiding down there.
Other survivors.
Oh, look.
There's the door.
But I want to explore.
Oh, broken.
A wine cellar.
Oh.
Ah, frog!
Thank you for the Hakusuba!
Number one combo, fries and some nuggets.
I can hear him coming down the hallway.
I need to hide, but I don't know where.
I now know this is not an exit or a resting place.
It's just another specimen room.
I think he's outside the door now.
Uh-oh.
No,
no, no, no.
I'm hiding.
Can you?
Can you see me?
Wait, will you actually be able to see me?
Oh my god, scary.
That's actually really scary.
Oh my gosh.
He can smell you, take a bath, stinky.
He can smell you guys!
He can smell!
I'm getting a heck of... Oh.
Everything is broken.
I don't want to die here.
Locked.
Upstairs maybe?
I can smell.
Everything is locked!
Oh.
I somehow managed to get away, but I don't know for how
long.
I hear him.
Even when I...
No, he's not there.
It's like he isn't even real, but instead of my own...
Instead of my own fears manifesting themselves and stalking
me.
Can I hide in here?
Is there a key?
Uh.
You only watch you, Mint.
I am.
No!
Watch whoever you want to watch.
Did I miss something?
Hmm.
Key in the fireplace?
Oh!
Bedroom key.
Thank you!
Oh.
Maybe upstairs is a bedroom.
Or down here.
I watch everyone except mint.
Oh wait, this is where we came from.
He can, guys, you know, he knows how to smell.
He knows how to smell, he knows how to smell, he knows how
to smell.
I can smell.
So scary.
I see.
No way, he can smell and he can see.
Yes, I think he has all five senses, you guys.
This is bad.
Oh, wait, what's this over here?
The music is awesome.
What is this?
Wow, a mansion.
Inside another mansion.
Maybe I've made it all the way to the end of the house.
Maybe this is like a resting place or another entrance
perhaps.
Whatever the case, I think this is a good spot to rest.
Well, you were wrong.
Uh-oh, there's nowhere to hide in there.
Uh-oh.
The music is a bop.
Parlor key?
What other rooms have I missed?
Maybe here?
Uh, this was broken.
This was broken.
the other side where is patty right this is broken that was
that room where did I miss here?
Is this the parlor?
no
was it this one?
no wait I went in here this was the other bedroom what am I
missing?
yeah hear me next time
this was maybe one of these I'm so... Am I stupid?
Broken, broken.
Huh?
He'll taste me next time!
Boom, boom, boom.
Oh, no, this is...
Uh, maybe down here?
Ah!
Oh my god.
Hide.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom!
He's gonna taste me!
Don't taste me, mister!
You'll like being dead.
I promise.
I do, actually.
Am I safe?
He left a cake.
I can't believe he didn't say I here.
I picked up the book.
And, um...
To the library?
I taste cake.
I read.
I mean...
Oh.
Are you...
winning mint um no no no i'm not no i'm not no i'm not
winning i feel very oh my god oh my god
this is so icky it makes me so claustrophobic there's too
much particles what is that what is that um what is it like
when the air is like super still and hasn't been touched in
a long time, dead air or something.
Can I hide in here?
I'm scared.
Oh, hide.
How'd you get down here?
I can't tell if he can like see me in here, which is why I'm
hiding in the corner.
Playing amnesia now.
I know, right!
We can smell you.
You're in the basement.
Have fun, Mint.
I think.
Execute.
Now getting out of here is probably going to be the tougher
part.
I'm sure of it.
God, this makes me feel so gross.
I hate it.
Oh my god.
No way.
That was so close.
Was everything green before?
That was red, wasn't it?
Oh my god.
Wait, is this?
Ah!
I thought it was the guy!
I thought it was...
I thought it was the guy that needs to stay close to me.
Not the man!
But he can't go through the goop either, right?
Yeah!
We're both goopless!
Oh my god.
He is not giving up.
Ooh, chains.
Oh my god.
So if he sees me, he goes like crazy, he goes sickle mode.
I think he starts like running crazy, right?
Oh my god.
Demon noises.
It's so scary.
Okay.
That's why these hallways are some of the scarier ones.
Oh my god.
Never mind.
He's just going sickle mode instead.
Oh my god.
Oh I went the wrong way.
Oh shoot.
I can't tell what he looks like when he makes that noise.
I can't tell at all.
Please, please end my misery!
Your imagination is scarier either way.
Oh goodness.
Look at the chains!
P&D chains!
Ah!
I
still caught him in half.
I think I at least gave this guy a candle.
Plus one violence.
Actually, I just wanted to see if it would happen.
It's not that it was because he was a ghost.
It just was because he was there.
You know?
It wasn't because he was a ghost.
It was because...
He was my little experiment.
You think that'll hold up in court?
There could only be one ghost.
Ah!
See, I'll do it to him too!
Ha ha ha!
840.
We've been at this for three hours.
Jack Lantern.
Ooh, skinny hallway.
Does that sound?
What's that sound?
Wait, the axe causes a bad ending if you use it too much?
No way?
Even if I don't use it on anything?
Even if I just swing it around town?
There's a counter.
Oh, if you kill too many monsters with it.
Well, what about the...
Oh, I guess they count as monsters because they were in the
specimen book.
Oh, shoot.
No.
I'm thinking Arby's.
I'm thinking... I'm not thinking Arby's!
Please!
Ah!
Okay, I won't kill you anymore!
The Deli Demon.
He's still after me.
Oh, shoot.
This way.
We got the meat.
Oh my god.
Why is it sometimes... Does he get too close?
And that's why it starts flashing.
I swear
I'll go vegetarian after this I swear I'll never eat another
burger please just let me go armies oh no the music stopped
I thought we were good oh he's still after me
very much after.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my god.
Oh, wait, did I...
I thought he was still after me, but he wasn't.
Oh, my gosh.
We made it at the best possible room.
I'm scared, Minto.
Don't be scared.
I'll get you through this.
We're just...
I thought it was the I didn't realize it was the creepy
crawly I thought it was the guy I gotta keep close I thought
it was the guy I gotta keep close Nope I see them on the
ceiling now Oh it's because the ceilings I think were high
before Oh my gosh That's so funny Yeah I can't see it from
here The ceilings were too high It's over?
What are you talking about?
It ain't over till the fat lady...
Oh, oh, stamina?
Ah, ice cream!
We made it!
gamers don't look up not gonna lie completely forgot about
that guy he was like don't forget about me creepy creepy cry
because we've gotten the goop guys so many times I've
completely forgotten about that guy the one I'm always not
prepared for is the oh oh my gosh oh
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I went the wrong way.
Wait, I went the wrong way, please.
There he is.
I'm always not prepared for the puppet.
This guy, though, we can handle.
888!
I like how I realize it went the wrong way as I went the
wrong way though.
Minto gaming.
Have I died to the puppet yet?
No, but now I probably will, because I just jinxed myself.
Don't you want to look at the lovely starry night?
Bonk, bonk.
Oh, you didn't even knock that one.
You just...
you did yeah there are two knocks i think two knock you
can't just knock once and then expect someone to let you in
you know you have to knock twice give them a second to to
answer the door they might be you know on the toilet and
need a second okay
you want a snack you want some ribs no you're good he's like
I'm I'm all ribs I'm only ribs look at me look at me Minto
how am I gonna eat ribs I'm all ribs
sorry can I get too far away from this guy he's really needy
he's really really needy what oh don't don't get too far
okay I thought there was gonna to be a door right there.
That was my mistake.
Yeah, loop the music.
Loop the music.
You're still here.
And 900!
Oh, that's my footsteps.
Oh my god, I thought he was knocking.
What did that say?
This is the first time I've ever seen someone who knows that
it's not over until the fat lady sings quote.
I sometimes say that to people when they say something, it's
over and they never get it.
Really?
I thought was a common thing, right?
I thought he was knocking.
Oh my gosh.
We got a hundred rooms left, everybody.
Oh,
maybe people don't say it anymore, right?
It's just a common phrase.
Is it because we're old?
Boomer phrase?
Definitely used to be common.
Oh, nice.
Straight!
Donk!
Left!
Left, left, right!
Straight!
Wow!
Vinto Gaming!
Ooh, it's really dark and dreary down here.
First try.
craziness.
100 more pull-ups!
It's about opera, and we don't opera as much as we used to.
I guess that's so true.
She's still going.
I didn't expect to finish the game today, but I don't know.
Maybe I will.
I mean, I'm not...
I mean, I think I will.
I'm at 900.
I might as well, right?
Okay.
I might as well.
I think.
Unless there's like a secret like...
You get to 1000, but it's not really.
Oh gosh.
It's water.
Okay, what's the gimmick here?
Broken.
Oh!
Researcher?
Oh, we're in the ocean.
Does anybody have a Thassus-less phobia?
Whale 015D has died much sooner than I expected while I was
away on holiday.
I regret not being here, but I had estimated it would live
much longer.
The team that did the autopsy said nothing seemed to be
wrong with the lungs, but the stomach had a circular hole
about two feet in diameter all the way through...
to the outside of the whale.
This pretty much confirms a parasite is the cause of death.
Oh, not the whale.
This guy seems healthy.
He seems alive and whale.
Researcher report five.
The research facility is now in dire need of more engineers.
We had a whole block that is flooded and some vital staff
are missing.
Uh-oh.
I don't like that.
I don't know what to expect in here.
I'm truly scared.
It's too dark to see.
Okay.
That's never stopped us before, but sure.
We're reading these all out of order.
Yeah, amnesia time.
That's the vibes I'm getting now, too.
No!
Whale 015A is still alive, but gets into fits of thrashing,
and is surfacing more often than natural.
I think there may be a problem with its lungs, but I don't
have many.
tools that would allow me to check it without it dying.
I will have to allow it to die from whatever is causing it
and then do an autopsy.
Aww.
Oh.
Whale 14D has strange small bite marks.
They appear from another small mammal.
But the strangest thing about them is their placement.
They are an even rose inside the whale's stomach.
All about 5 feet from the bottom of the stomach lining.
Okay, I'm reading these literally all out of order.
100% out of order.
Oh, gonna say room with nothing in it.
Excerpt 4, 132.
And then I watched carelessly as the sea rose above the sky,
casting waving shadows over the world.
I saw the silhouettes of creatures both familiar and
forgotten.
Suddenly, I found myself falling upwards towards an ocean of
darkness.
Lantern?
There's a lantern in here?
Oh!
Oh my gosh it was too dark to see
oh broken
oh how am i supposed to do each one oh turn okay wait how do
i turn it oh there we go yeah how i've been doing every
action is it four four four
read research report number one more whales are being
shipped to the facility tomorrow one for health inspection
and two that already died dead for autopsies more and more
beached whales keep appearing around those islands and i
can't figure find what is causing it i always miss these
notes that are on the ground the water's too high oh so the
excerpt was what was the number
4132 research report 6 I hear a girl or an animal or
something singing to me pleading that I come outside my
locked room and let the sweeping waves comfort me uh
A siren?
I would fall for that.
Don't admit that so easily.
Oh gosh.
I'm scared.
The lantern got snuffed out.
Oh my gosh, this is actually amnesia!
No way.
Well, I know.
When something is around.
I see like a trail.
And can it get me on here?
I'm going to imagine not, because that would be unfair.
Oh, gosh.
Eek!
Fish wife.
Oh, there's a note there.
All the staff is gone.
Only I remain.
For no purpose, I remain here resisting the call from behind
the sealed door.
But I will remain as long as I can.
Don't open that door!
Is it this one?
I sure hope so.
Wait, was there a note in here that I missed?
Uh.
Did I open the rock?
Mr. Which door?
Can you tell me which one?
Mr. I think you have to say which door.
door open this one wait a second let's try this real quick
don't open that door oh I got a key oh and this is probably
the key to open the door isn't it
I'm gonna open it and then like
She's beautiful.
Wait a second.
I mean...
Should I...
I think she's topless.
You guys...
You guys, I think she's topless though!
Um...
Ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma
You haven't seen her face?
I mean, look at that.
Look at the assets!
I can see them from the fog!
I can see them through the fog!
What are you talking about?
The face?
Come on!
Eating mermaid flesh grants immortality?
If I...
Go...
Is she gonna stay there?
Uh...
Okay.
Is this like something trigger?
I'm nervous, you know?
She's still there.
I should look around first.
Okay.
Go closer?
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm being a little baby.
I am being a bit of a baby.
Oh, she's like camping.
No way.
Oh, she's camping, camping.
She wants you mint.
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
oh my god oh my god oh she comes in through here
she's down there did it hurt a lot she's a little yandere
i can't tell what oh i think she came out and then turned
around
nice uh the water is draining Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, oh.
Okay, this is the end of this area.
What are you doing, lovely?
Just ask around what's the worst that could happen.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
That's what I'm saying.
Sure, we'll be fine.
Let's all wait for our health to...
Rededereya.
Whew, she was fast.
I like an aggressive lady.
She's feisty.
Yeah, she's feisty.
Leave a hickey.
Calm down, everybody.
Calm down.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
Whew, hoo, hoo.
She went that way, so I'm gonna go.
This way.
Yes?
She's drawing hearts in the water for me.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god.
At least she leaves this time.
You know?
You're not you when you're hungry.
Okay, I think I can make it.
Nine.
13.
Oh, I was gonna say I should just go for it, but I'm glad I
didn't.
Does she come back, I wonder?
These last rooms take a long time to clear.
I can imagine, yeah.
She come back.
Okay, let's give it a second to see.
Are you going to play the DLC?
Um, probably at some point, but not today.
I would like to at some point, I think it'd be fun.
Oh my gosh, I don't know where she is.
She sounds pretty far, though.
There she is.
This water doesn't look sanitary.
It's as cleanly as the sand.
which they will be swimming in for the Olympics.
Oh,
gosh.
I tried to juke her.
Get out of here.
Are you camping me again?
Wait, no, she turned around.
There she goes.
Love bite.
My first
time with a mermaid.
There she is.
This is how we communicate.
She draws, you know, stuff in the water.
It's for me to read.
Little love notes.
It kind of looks like a slug when she's not, like, above the
water, you know?
giving real sluggy energy here.
Oh, I didn't know where she was.
Oh, where'd she go, actually?
I think she went down that way.
Oh,
she backtracked.
That was about to go.
Where'd she?
Okay, I think she went all the way down.
I think we're...
Oh, oh!
Oh, not good, not good, not good.
Is she going to backtrack here again?
Yep.
Oh.
Half slug, half made.
A mermaid.
I don't think that's how that works.
I don't think that's where the mer part comes from.
I might be wrong.
Okay,
so she can now go through under here.
I don't know where she is, though.
So, bro!
Ah!
You're up soon.
Hey, a slug girl is just a poor man's slime girl.
I wasn't hating on a slug girl.
I wouldn't discriminate monster girls.
I love monster girls.
Thanks for the don't know.
She's sending me...
She's saying triangle, as in like, you know...
This isn't bad.
It's...
Oh my god.
It's not gray triangle.
Actually, she wants to listen to triangle from Macross right
now.
That's what she's saying.
Wait, that's not triangle.
I'm singing the rock song.
Triangle Dreamer.
She's a regular triangle.
That's lion.
Yeah, I know.
Wait, how does triangle go again?
I don't mind this one so much.
It's just a matter of patience, you know.
At least I don't mind it right now.
Murphy brought up a great point.
What about mermaid maids?
and merm...
Man...
Mates.
Sheesh.
Um...
Mermaid.
Mermaids.
Are you saying I should get a mermaid outfit?
Oh no, wait, which way do I go?
No, no, I don't know.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I don't know where to go.
Is this a dead end?
I can't tell!
Oh god.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, there's a door here!
Hopefully it's okay!
Yes!
Gosh.
How long does this last for?
Oh, did I just go in a circle?
Oh, oh, oh my god.
I didn't just go in a circle, did I?
No.
There she's going.
There it is.
The door.
Ah.
She just went that way.
Don't know where she went though.
Oh, there she is.
Go through there.
No.
Go through the...
Go through the grate.
Okay.
Give it a second, yep.
Does she always...
Is she just like in a triangle?
Oh!
Okay.
Again, she's sending me signals.
So when she comes back...
Oh.
Oh, that's different from the pattern that I've just been
observing.
Come!
And she's left.
She, like, comes at me and then turns around.
So it makes it way...
No!
Just gonna have to go for it?
Madam, please!
She is really quick, and they're way less.
I don't even know where the next one is.
What is?
Ah!
There's the door.
Oh my gosh!
Okay.
Still not quite good, but...
Come on!
You can't go down any lower.
Okay.
Oh, there she is.
We want to at least let us see the bubbles before we...
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I can't even see like the...
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Could I use a worm?
Dang!
Holy cow!
I think this is a smaller room, so it's a little bit
trickier.
There she is, going back towards the crate that we need to
get to!
No warning, going en route.
Going en route.
I was gonna say, I think from here we just ran for it!
That one was tough.
Holy cow.
How much longer?
924, baby.
75 rooms, no way.
We have to go through all the rooms like this.
Oh.
Oh, I thought.
I thought.
I really thought.
This is actually torture.
Did she... Where'd she go?
Oh.
Five more rooms of this tops, actually.
Or are you pulling my leg?
I can't tell.
Time sync?
I think the bladder level is more of a time sync than it is
one.
That's the kind of the vibe I'm...
It's definitely... It is overstayed its welcome, I think.
I've done more than enough rooms of this.
I feel like it's kind of a good thing that it was, that this
is like in the home stretch of the game.
Because otherwise, I feel like this would filter a lot of
people.
Like if, imagine if this was in like 300, I think I would
have been like, nah, I think I'm good.
But at this point, you're so far in, you don't even, you're
like, well, made it this far I can't just quit so it ends up
becoming like a sunk cost
fallacy I
feel like so close but so far like I'm like any any room the
next room will surely be it you know like you can't do this
you can't do this the whole the for 75 more rooms that'd be
craziness
Oh my gosh, please.
Please, let me out of this hellscape.
Bring me back to Arby's.
Oh, okay.
This is a dead end.
Of course it is.
Fish, girlfriend, I need a break.
I'm not breaking up with you.
It's you.
It's not, I mean, it's me.
It's not you.
It's you just a little bit, but I just, I just need a bit of
a break, please.
Yeah, go in there.
There's so much going on in there.
At some point, I'm just, I'm just going for it.
I'm like, I can't even be bothered.
Please, please, please put me out of my misery.
Girlfriend!
Maybe 930 will be the last of it.
I sure hope so.
Surely by 930.
Oh my gosh.
I'm getting a little braver with it.
Actually, I don't know if it's bravery or impatience.
Oh my god, please!
Oh, that was close.
Sylvan, thank you!
Welcome to Membushu!
Girlfriend!
That was so close.
Oh gosh.
Yikes.
It's okay, she's leaving.
She wants you so bad.
Collegiate!
Thank you so much for the birthday!
Oh.
I got a achievement marathon.
Just keep moving.
I'm trying.
Thank you so much!
I really, really, really appreciate it!
Thank you!
I mean, I did a 50 earlier!
Thank you so much.
Just keep moving, says the game.
Just keep moving.
I'm just...
It's like a mosquito, you know?
I'm just too tasty.
Too tasty.
That was so scary.
Behind me.
Chocolate mint flavored.
There she goes.
And there I go.
Oh my god.
I just want to have a word with the devs.
Jeez!
I just don't want to have a word with the devs, please.
There is at some point when something becomes too much.
It's not scary anymore.
It's just frightening.
It's just frustrating.
Literally like every...
I feel every indie horror game does this at some point, you
know?
Every indie horror game has a part where it's just...
It has overstayed its welcome!
Oh, section is giraffe.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I'm trying to make it entertaining.
Wait.
Hold on.
Let's wait for her to turn around.
Still made you jump?
Yeah, because she attacked me.
Please.
Oh my gosh.
According to wiki mermaid Ending End to N30 No What It has
to be maybe N30 9 I said N as if like Because you know 9
starts with the N 940 Okay 940 Okay You're the cutest ghost
mate.
Oh, stop it.
Okay, how many ghost mates do you actually know, though?
Have you guys seen the latest Tonto Kauri pack?
Have you seen?
If you have not seen the latest Tonto Kauri pack, I'm kind
of just like...
I'm like side-eyeing it a little bit.
Because it's literally me!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Wait, but the water went down!
There's more!
Tanto Kairi is a...
is a...
a made card game.
940, right?
Aoi-chan!
Let's let... I'm gonna let my... me heal again just in case.
Oh, looks like an oldノge with that art style.
Isn't that the best though?
Please, please, please, please.
Oh my god, I didn't realize she was right there.
No, no, no, no, no.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please.
Why does it keep going?
I'm gonna look at the new expansion pack.
I love Tanto Quarry.
Yeah.
I forgot how to play this game now.
I'm not gonna lie.
We were in there for so long, I forgot how to play normally.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, it's the brain.
Freedom!
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Mr. Abizi, thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you!
But I'm kind of more nervous now because at least with...
At least with the mermaid, was predictable you know what I
mean now I'm just like what's gonna happen but just 50 left
I would love a save right now I know right gosh oh gosh
I'm our wispy friend oh we're back here so
Specimen...
Did we do 12 before?
Oh, the mansion, that's right.
Oh, yeah, we went in here.
Wait, so there's nothing else?
There's, they don't even have a thing on the mermaid.
Right?
Huh.
This one, what is this one?
Have I seen this one?
I have no idea.
visiting.
Dang it.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Should be specimen 13.
No, there isn't one.
I don't know which one it is.
Ah!
This guy!
I don't like the sound he makes.
the sound he makes it's so scary
just some guy you know he can smell me he can hear me he can
see me he can see
oh my gosh sniff a man my beloved he's like really he says
where are you oh Is that what he's doing?
He is so obsessed with me!
Oh, I think we made it through.
969!
Oh,
a different kind of room.
Really threw me off for a second.
Oh, goodness, great.
We're so close.
What is this new music?
Horror of a dude with at least three senses.
He'll never get the fifth sense.
He'll never...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh, is this guy?
I forgot he busts down the door.
Oh, you're too weak to deal with the...
bridge?
Um, knock him out.
Uh, what was I gonna say?
Oh yeah, he'll never reach the last one, which is touch.
Okay.
20 left!
Meow.
Or taste.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, you're right.
You'll never taste me alive!
Ah!
Tom and Jerry, that's reaction!
Shut up!
Oh my god, what was that?
What was that on the right side?
I don't even want it all.
She really mastered the goofy impression.
What impression?
Are you calling me goofy?
Let's go to the leftist arm.
Eight.
Seven.
Six.
Five.
Why is it?
GL Labs!
Wait, why is it giving me a save at five left?
Keep that blood pumping!
Wait!
Five more, but why do we have a save?
I'm scared!
This seems ominous.
Extremely so.
Well, we saved!
So I feel a little less...
bad.
Here we go.
What do you mean by that?
I don't know what to expect at all.
Especially considering the fact that... That's the halfway
point.
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Nope.
I'm scared when you guys say that!
Three?
Two?
What's gonna happen?
Go towards the light!
What light?
Literally?
Oh, axe!
I forgot I had it!
Yippee!
Oh, the world is so much cuter than I thought it would be!
Oh, I can't go around the building.
Oh my gosh, window XP!
Bye bye!
Oh, no if I'm trapped in here.
Oh.
Is that me?
Portal moment?
You made it.
Congratulations.
I guess.
Uh, well.
Oh.
So now you must pass one final test.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Or something.
I have no stamina.
I'm taking all those logs that keep throwing out.
And I'm nailing them together.
Okay.
Oh!
I still have the axe.
Oh.
731?
731.
What the hell was that?
Sorry.
Is this your room?
Ah!
Oh!
Uh-oh.
What are you gonna do?
You won't take me!
Come down here!
You!
You coward!
Bloody, bloody!
Yeah,
I can't jump.
Here's the BFG.
How am
I supposed to get him?
He's like squirming.
He's doing hands.
He's getting handsy with me.
Oh!
Oh, that one hurt me.
Oh, can I, um, maybe...
Oh, nice!
Take that!
Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Yeah!
What's it take
to kill this guy?
Handsy.
Handsy bastard.
Oh, I don't think I can reflect this one.
I'm assuming.
I'm assuming I cannot reflect that one.
But I will try.
This one!
Double hand!
Oh my god!
Now there's probably gonna be like five guys!
Ah, four guys!
Close enough!
Ouchie, ouchie.
Okay, this one probably I can't reflect then, right?
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh, when it's red!
Okay, okay, okay.
I think I get it.
Cool.
It's
cool when it's red, right?
Only when it's not red?
Damn!
Oh, nice, nice.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Okay, I have to be careful with this one though.
Okay.
Oh, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I missed my chance!
Oh!
No!
That's me.
That's me right now.
Okay.
These guys.
That would help if I actually could hit them.
Oh, please.
Hit
it when it's red.
It's fine.
Oh!
Well, I didn't need to.
Yippee!
Silence!
Well, you died.
In a pretty tragic way too.
Just tragic enough.
Oh, for you to become a ghost.
Good job, by the way, making it this far.
So buckle up, soldier.
Because now, I finally think we have enough troops to
invade.
I'm...
Where are we going?
Are we invading heaven?
What are we invading?
I died after all that!
The time has come, my loyal troops.
No, no,
will we be disregarded and ignored?
For now, we are the most feared army in the world.
MSF!
Did you really think it was going to end seriously?
What do you mean?
You'll win!
I can speed it up.
Sorry, sorry, developers.
That's so evil.
Wow, there's a bunch...
There's a couple names in here that I recognize.
That's so silly.
Vinesauce!
Matara's been talking to that guy.
Spank, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Shout outs to vinesauce.
If you're too violent and break things with the axe too
much, instead of the ghost ending, you become a specimen
yourself.
Ah, I see, I see.
Ducky, thanks to the vinesauce.
I'm gifted!
Funny ghost made.
No longer will we be called funny or cute.
We will invade!
It's funny because when Matara was just like, oh yeah, I
collabed with a guy named Vine Sauce the other day.
Like the first time she collabed with him, I was just like,
what?
You collabed with Vinny?
She was like, yeah, I don't know who that is.
And I was like, this is, are we in a parallel universe?
Where I know who someone is and you don't know who someone
is?
I thought it was funny.
I felt like that too.
I was like, what?
I feel like Matara is lying.
She should know who Vinny...
No, she said she didn't know.
But I was like, you know every Twitch person.
GG, funny and cute ghost.
No!
what we were called!
Funny or cute!
We are!
We are the Ghost Revolution!
This music...
Okay, hold on.
What was a...
Was it under Options?
That the music was kind of chill?
Yeah.
I like the music here.
Can't wait to see you lead the Ghost Revolution.
Fun game, even if the water level overstayed its welcome.
Yeah, no.
It was still really fun.
frog please your wallet thank you for the 50 thank you so
much thank you thank you thank you are you okay your wallet
though congrats on being the game funny and cute ghost
funny cute you got the wrong guy
i don't think i've ever been funny and cute in my life You
got the wrong guy.
I'm just clowning around.
What does crowd control do?
What's crowd control?
Wait, and the...
Oh, crowd control.
I see it.
That's a great question.
Disconnected.
Crowd control allows Twitch.tv viewers to influence the game
while broadcasting.
Why is it only Twitch.tv?
Note that crowd control is less effective in Karamari
Hospital and the dollhouse.
Only Twitch.
This is the only good thing about Twitch.
Because you can do silly things like that.
There's so many things, ways to connect with your chat and
stuff.
Common YouTube L But don't worry I don't ever have plans on
streaming on Twitch If you were just like Oh she's getting
more and more convinced First it's marbles Now it's crowd
control No no don't worry I don't want to stream on Twitch
Thank God for that Minto no longer a funny and cute ghost
from this day on.
It's been real, y'all.
No.
Goodstream gave me lots of ideas for art, especially art
involving slime girls and mint.
Wait, your name.
I'm worth.
Cute sans frontiers.
You can encounter the dead guy early if you're AFK for too
long or in an endless hallway.
Oh, then what do you do with him?
Oh, does he just kill you?
From what I understand, this game is about a ghost maid who
cleans up her delinquent master's mansion, gets lost in
sewers, somehow becomes even stinkier.
Congrats on the wait window.
I am very curious.
I know, hold on.
We'll come back to the nice music in a second.
Um, instead of this almost penis music.
Um, yeah, the Karamari Hospital unlocked the secrets of the
Strange Abandoned Hospital.
spell and then the dollhouse and then you can eventually you
can build your own mansion that seems so fun this one seems
like for an insane person actually endless mode seems like
if you actually are insane
this is so relaxing even when you even when you in twitch
chat folks don't believe it i know
Gosh, this music is so nice.
I wish I had this as like a normal BGM.
I know we're not there yet, but do you have any spooky plans
for October?
Actually, yes.
Well, first off, my birthday's in October.
October 1st, everybody.
And this mode eventually, you get multiple monsters at once.
It's actually pretty interesting.
Again, we're insane people.
And then, not 31st?
No, no.
I died on October 1st.
Not the 31st.
I say it's my birthday.
It's my death day.
Birth is a ghost.
So, mine is October 20th.
October Twinsies!
What do you want for your birthday, Minto?
Well, we still have plenty of time.
I know what I want.
gonna hope for it.
I'm gonna build my own mansion with slime girls and maids.
You know what?
Forget the mansion.
Wait, you forgot the blackjack.
Tootspace and blackjack!
Happy birthday.
Thanks, Murphy.
Summer birthday.
October 1st is my half birthday.
What does that mean?
When you when you You were...
You...
Vetus?
Glad you liked the game.
The dev has made a lot of other good games like Lost in
Vivo.
And Luna said, if you have an itch for more.
Wait, I've heard of Lost in Vivo before.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, there's locked achievements too.
Oh, these are like the Caramari.
The Calamari Hospital.
Wait, if I go to their store page...
Sorry, you can hear it.
Lost in Vivo.
Wait.
Is it not on Steam?
Katamari Hospital.
Katamari Damasi.
Lunasit is inspired by Proto Dark Souls games.
Oh, neat.
Marikami!
Thanks for the ice cream.
It's on Steam.
Wait, lost.
Why wasn't it showing up for me?
Oh, whoa.
Sorry, you can hear it.
A horror game about claustrophobia.
Whoa.
I feel like maybe I've seen a let's play of this or
something.
Or maybe I'm crazy.
Ew.
Looks icky.
I...
I'm very much of the mindset where, like I said earlier, I'm
pretty picky about my horror game tastes.
I typically like more Fatal Frame style.
I'm not a huge fan of, like, monsters, because they don't
really scare me, typically, you know.
Well, what's not?
What's not a spam, please?
But, uh, you like ghosts.
You like when he can't fight back?
I guess so, maybe.
Hmm.
I don't think it's that it's fighting back.
I just like, I just think it scares me more.
And I like things that scare me.
Even though they scare me.
Oh, I've played a little bit of Siren before.
Oh, Kuhon.
I've never, I haven't played that one, actually.
Wait.
Kuhon.
Juhon?
Kuhon is a game though, isn't it?
What about Ghostbusters?
Kek W.
Those guys are...
Those guys are phonies.
Yeah, Kuhon...
I don't think I ever had it.
Calling!
Yes, I loved calling!
I loved calling.
System Shock 2 has ghosts in it.
What about System Shock 1?
A cheat horror 2?
Like, live stream?
Yes!
Yeah.
I just...
I love...
I like horror more like that.
But it's also not the popular kind of horror, I think.
I think horror, like, monster horror, Resident Evil type
horror and stuff is more popular.
So unfortunately, because more people are just like, or
like, you know,
like, oh, there's a serial killer stalking.
Yeah, stuff like that is more popular.
This game's DLC would be fun for Halloween lead-up.
You know what?
That's a great idea.
It's kind of far from me playing it.
Like, you know, I'm finishing it, the game in July, but it
would be fun to, to play the DLC and stuff maybe in um in
Halloween I'll add it to my calendar so I don't forget
calendar calendar calendar we'll do it there um spooky man
spooky's mansion DLC Calamari How Can I do a boat?
Do you think I can do both DLCs in one stream?
Calamari Hospital
And Dollhouse
Or are they pretty long I think?
It's possible?
Are you going to play the Silent Hill 2 Remake on stream?
I I think I will.
Even though I'm very...
I'm hesitant.
It's Bloober Team.
So I'm hesitant.
And apparently the new Nintendo game is also Bloober Team.
The Emio.
I'm nervous.
I'm not a big fan of Bloober Team.
Have you played Signalus?
I have.
I really like Signalus.
It was pretty spooky too.
Corral!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
MEO isn't Bloober?
I thought...
I thought people figured out it was.
I saw a source say it could not be Bloober.
Oh!
Have you played Yomawari?
Yes.
Before I went to heaven, actually, I played Yomawari.
But I haven't played Yomawari, too.
But I have a little bit of trauma Yomawari.
Trauma.
Karateka, you remember.
I have a little bit of trauma from the final boss of
Yomawari.
You couldn't beat it?
No, I did.
Just with a lot of swearing.
Lord keeper, welcome.
Look up old game Cosmology?
Wait, Cosmology of Kyoto is from Or from Soft's old game,
Kuan.
Like I said, I am familiar with Kuan, just a little bit.
But Cosmology of Kyoto.
This one I've never heard of before.
1993.
Never heard this one before.
for.
Is it?
Whoa.
Interesting.
Is it like a visual novel?
What is this?
A visual mindscape of Old Japan.
This looks really interesting.
I have no idea.
What the gameplay?
Oh my gosh.
Sorry, I'm looking at Google ImageGoogles.
Images, wait.
Have you played the Watson Scott test?
It's a personality test like game.
Could show your IP address.
Oh, I don't want that to happen.
But I haven't played.
You know, Alan Wake is pretty spooky.
Wink Wink.
I have Alan Wake.
I did buy it.
And I got my Epic Games account back.
So I could play it.
Soma, oh, a lot of people have been, or rather, I always see
Soma recommended.
Glad to be here with me for a month.
Ah, Aaron, thank you!
Thanks for a month.
Juwan the Grudge on the Wii U.
I, yes, I, when someone said Kuwan earlier, I was just like,
wait, the Juwan Grudge game for the Wii.
FMV games, like seventh guest or, oh, I know, I don't know
seventh guest.
The seventh guest.
But I do know Phantasmagoria.
You guys are always giving such interesting recommendations.
Deadly Premonition.
I have that also on my list.
Probably will do it.
Probably sometime in August.
I want to play it.
Just nine more months.
Until what?
Until what, Haru?
Scarlet Hollow.
It's a spooky visual novel.
Same team that made Slay the Princess.
No way, really!
I love Slay the Princess.
Scarlet...
Hollow.
I love how this has suddenly turned into like a game
recommendation corner.
Ooh, it's kind of creepy.
I'll look into it.
Thank you.
the princess is so good another recommendation and easier to
get disillusion
faith i think i'll play faith during october as well though
i've played them before is that okay lost in vivo oh yeah
yeah yeah we were we were just talking about that random
faith is great Okay, if I play it again?
I thought you said fate.
No, faith.
Minto, you already went through the entire game?
I have!
I'm a gamer.
I went through it, baby.
Mortis.
I'll add that to October.
Faith trilogy.
I don't think I'll be able to do all of three in the same
day, but...
Hmm.
Ah.
Great collab game.
Oh, yes.
Actually, Matara and I keep trying to do a deep rock
galactic collab.
Maybe with like Henya or something.
Hmm.
So.
Corpse party.
I love corpse party.
Broken star.
They're making a new chapter for faith.
No way, really?
Erdorf?
I want to work with that guy.
Minto game.
Be kind of crazy.
Did someone say Rockin' Stone?
Rockin' Stone!
I haven't played... I saw actually at AX.
They had several areas where you could play Corpse Party 2.
It's in 3D.
I don't know how to feel about it.
But also, there was a corpse party too already.
It was like set in a hospital.
I never played it.
I only played.
I used to... I loved...
I think her name was Naho from Corpse Party.
There's one line, though.
Yeah, Naho.
I really loved her.
I even cosplayed her at one point.
But, um...
Uh...
There's one line.
If you know Corpse Party, you know...
know the famous the infamous line but i played regular
corpse party and then i played what book of shadows i didn't
play the satchiko's birthday one the butter brochebug nose
ralette nose butter the pooper
doki talked a lot about corpse party on stream before did i
wait has she played it?
I'll have to ask her.
I didn't think she liked horror.
But I guess it's, I don't know.
It's not scary, but the atmosphere is very, very creepy.
The sound design in the game is very, very good, I think.
There's one ending that you can get, like one death ending
where you get buried alive, and like, it just actually makes
me choke, because it's so ugh!
It's so The sound design is so good.
The voice actors are so good.
Hungry Ghosts for the PS2 could be interesting.
Hungry Ghosts.
Whoa!
Why does this look older than a PS2 game?
It's only in Japanese.
Mihongo only.
Look.
looks maybe to be the case.
Oh, I think I have I have so many games, though.
I'll ask for a recommendation.
If you want to leave a recommendation in the comments or
something for me to for me to what's the word?
Go over in the future, then you know.
That would be the best because otherwise I'll forget.
You may need I love Yume Niki, though.
Maybe, yeah, maybe.
There's like the 3D Yume Niki, but it's like not the same,
right?
Night Trap.
Very infamous FMV.
That more or less led to the ESRB's creation?
Really?
Wait, I have heard of Night Trap, though.
Never mind, just kidding.
Thank you for defending Patamon.
I have heard of Night Trap But I've not played Night Trap
There was that one game that came out Just a couple years
ago At Dead of Night I think it was called It's not exactly
FMV Or maybe does it count?
Actually I don't know
But I've always It's It's like I've I want to play it, but I
think I would actually be too stressed for it.
Oh, dot flow.
Oh my God, dot flow.
I have, I have not heard of that game in so long.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, dot flow.
I completely forgot about dot flow until just now.
Wow.
Night trap requires a guide.
Night trap is so cheesy.
It looks like...
It looks like a...
80s, you know, like...
What's the word?
Like an 80s slasher.
Can't be horror.
I love that, though.
released on.
Is that Mega... Mega CD?
Sega CD.
Wow.
There is no gore though.
Little goody tush.
Oh yes, I've seen...
I've heard a lot of really good things about that.
Or rather...
Thank you, thank you.
The animation and everything.
I remember a while back you were talking about maybe only
being around till the end of the summer.
Now we're here discussing October plans.
Feels nice.
It's good to have you around.
Thank you, Silverade.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I think, uh...
I
don't know how to...
I think, like, I...
well I initially was just like coming back I wasn't sure you
know but I've talked with a lot of people like a lot a lot a
lot of people and it's kind of you know at first i was like
unsure of what direction to go and and stuff but you know
through a bunch of people's advice and um um uh experiences
i felt like maybe i should um go differently from my
original plan that I was thinking.
So I'm still even now like unsure if I'm even doing the
right thing I guess.
everything is so confusing.
I'm always just like why can't things be normal?
So.
But I do really love streaming and as if you guys will still
have me then you know I can be around I don't know for how
much longer but for the for the future I don't even know how
to say what what is considered long term anyway for seeing
future yeah yeah 50 years okay it's
just so still confusing to me everything but yeah i always
i'm always thinking about it like every day i'm like wow i
mean those brain goes
But I'm doing my best So Thanks for supporting me Thanks for
hanging out with me tonight Thanks for watching me go
through 1,000 rooms of Craziness Actually 1,000 rooms of
craziness Stream from the nursing home if you have to in a
movie.
Community never came back!
Thank you for being here to entertain us.
We're lucky to have you here.
Aw, thanks, Sean.
Myzoku!
Welcome to membership!
I never brought up, but I want a second Soma.
The story has stuck to me more than almost any other game
I've ever played.
It's not just scary, it's haunting.
It keeps haunting you after you finish.
Okay, I'll add it to our October.
I don't want to... I'm like, I'm always in the mood to play
spooky horror.
Try Princess, thank you!
You're always in the mood to play more horror, but I'm like,
maybe I should start gathering stuff for October.
Spooky, spooky month.
Soma.
Is that a game I can...
Let's see, how long to beat?
Soma.
As long as you're happy, we'll be happy.
We'll be especially happy for however long you keep
streaming.
Thank you.
I'll third Soma.
Oh, nine hours?
It's probably like what?
Oh, wait.
It took me about six.
No.
Probably like two to three streams.
Oh, my God.
I'm not going to say your name.
Oh, your name is Please.
Oh, you have such nice manners.
You have such nice manners.
What's most difficult for me right now is there's so many
games that I want to play that are kind of...
kind of long?
I'm trying not to be like, okay, let's play every long game
at once!
So it's nice to get some games in like this kind of that I
can do in one stream.
I try to balance it.
Like having, you know, obviously I'm doing Metal Gear, but
then I have like also Eternal Darkness, and then I do some
other in-between stuff as well.
It's like what Gray Fox says, just keep fighting for what
you believe in and we'll be there to support and laugh with
you.
Wow, thanks so much, Karen.
I was a hardcore lurker, VOD watcher, so I'm glad you're
back, Minto.
I decided I didn't want to miss out this time.
And your streams are the most fun, period.
Mints cute.
I'm excited for all that's next.
What?
No way!
You stopped being a lurker because I came back?
Yeah!
Ah!
Thank you!
But that's not to say also if you lurk, you know, you have
to stop lurking.
I appreciate everybody who watches at all.
Even you VOD watcher, I don't even know if a VOD watcher
would still be listening.
But, you know, lurkers, still a lurker.
Not anymore, I see you.
Not so common sense.
But, yeah.
If you, if you, if you, if you been watching since I first
debuted, if you came in between heaven, if you came after
heaven, if you lurk, if you chat all day every day, if you
spam in my chat.
If you have weird names like please pee on me, mint phantom.
If you, if you have, if you, I don't know, where was I
going?
Anyways, I appreciate you guys.
Mint appreciation tax.
Boopie!
You changed your profile picture.
What is that?
Boston.
She loves us.
I'm a newer subscriber.
I'll be happy to stick around for as long as you need your
fans.
Thank you!
Thank you.
you start watching after I came back.
Matara and I kind of covered, talked about this, I think in
the Patreon episode.
But someone asked a question on Patreon of the podcast
Patreon.
They were like, when do I become a whisperer or a Momo?
Since Matara's fan base is called Momo's.
They were like, when do you become a whisperer Momo?
Is it when you donate?
Is it when you chat?
Is it when you...
Oh my gosh, frog.
Thank you for the pink.
And it was like...
It's like, no.
They were like, were you a mo...
Do you have to be a mo-mo from day one?
It's like, no.
I joined a softball team.
I'm baseball filled now.
Boy.
When you sacrifice your soul.
Pretty much.
Hmm.
As soon as you take a step in here and allow me to absorb a
little bit of your life energy, you're basically a wisp.
Whoever that was, I was baseball-pilled, too.
We love Minto.
Thank you.
Azru, Kyle, Kohn, welcome.
Pariviko, welcome back.
Was also a lurker of Odd Watcher until your comeback and
didn't want to miss out.
No way!
That's so crazy.
That's so so crazy.
But again, you know, just being here.
You don't miss now.
I think?
Pyrobug!
Thanks for the tag gifted!
But yeah, you know, I'm just uh...
Usually Lyric, I'm just watching you while farming runes.
Keep farming them runes.
So if our official fan name is Whisp, I would like to
propose we canonize the name Pissy Whispy.
Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, Vitor,
Vitor, Vitor, Vitor, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, This is not a
democracy!
No!
That was bad post-English, Jizo.
Yeah, let's just, uh, we'll just ignore that and keep on
keeping on.
Oh, I just, sorry, I did not see you.
Phantom Inc.
Thanks for the gifted membership!
Sorry if I missed, uh, donos and stuff.
Um, while I was playing because sometimes it was hard to too
hard to reach out and also avoid all of these guys.
If you vetoed, does that make you a peace walker?
Oh wait, if you're vetoed, does that make you a peace
walker?
I like it.
She hates us.
Frogbird?
Frogbird is not vetoed.
He is webbed.
toad.
Oh my god, he's chronically online.
He's chronically on the worldwide webtoad.
Oh my gosh, that's what, you know, that's what like a feat,
a feat, a feat, a feat, a feat, a feat, a feat, a frog feet,
wiki would be called webtoes.
Hey cutie.
Hey, Meechies fries.
Your name is cut off, but is it still Mince Lies?
Someone reboot the mage.
You stuck on Re-feet?
Very glad to get to see you.
Stream your- and enjoy yourself.
For however long that works for you.
Listening to you up here or the podcast is a pleasure.
Miss Mint Fan Toilet.
That might be the worst nickname ever to come out.
That might be actually the worstest nickname anybody could
have given that to me.
Can you keep saying feet?
Feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet,
feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet,
feet, feet, feet, feet, feet, feet,
feet, me now anyways guys oh my gosh i just realized the
time i'm gonna go to sleep now i'm gonna go to bed um thank
you guys again for uh joining me for almost five hours of i
don't have to zoom in on the face uh getting me thanks to
the fine gifted thank you guys for hanging out with me i
hope you guys You guys have a nice night, morning,
afternoon, whatever time it is for you.
Oh, wait, oh, oh, ashes, thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Only just started interacting because I'm very shy despite
watching you since debut.
Don't worry, me too.
If you think you're shy, I'm more shy.
Thank you for always having such a kind space.
Ever since he came back, I've met other wisps, went to my
first concert, and even got my first penlight.
Thanks for being around, Mint.
Oh my gosh, we have a danger!
Thank you!
Do we have to duke it out?
No, wait.
Maybe?
If you want.
Julian, I don't know if yours will show up, because it might
be buried.
You've done so much these past three months, so proud of
you.
It's okay to take your time figuring things out.
you're happy doing what you want we're happy and we'll
support whatever direction you want to go love you me though
thank you first pen light that's always so exciting
oh thanks that's the one i just read hey mint your double
finger guns pretty good thank you george la-la-la-la Good
night, Minto.
I look forward to seeing you.
I'm Otaku-tan.
Thank you!
See you there.
Um, actually, it's funny you bring up the double finger guns
because you may enjoy a new email coming out.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
And that's all I will say.
Thank you, everybody, for watching.
Thanks for hanging out.
I really, really, really, really appreciate it.
so much.
And yeah, have a good day, have a good night.
Go see you guys next time.
Bye bye.
Good night.
Bye bye!
Guys,
I've got a thing today that allows me to move my hands in
3D!